[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys
i totally forgot that i even made like a
little christmas-centric sidetracks
thing although i didn't make like a like
a cardboard but it will i can't think of
everything
so happy holidays you guys christmas eve
i know oh my god man we cook so much
[ __ ] my tummy hurts yeah
i gotta turn the volume off
yeah
that's why we like wanted to wait until
like the show is later because we have
making a turkey and that wasn't going to
be done until that wasn't actually done
till like five almost so was it yeah
and that's gonna that's gonna take us a
week to eat all that i made three pies
yeah match millions of other things i
had stuff to do it so i did it i haven't
even had any of the pie left i couldn't
i had one plate if i had some turkey
you've made you made from scratch mashed
potatoes yeah
um stuffing cream corn all kind of stuff
um green banana
pumpkin pie
i made a um
we had apple pie made apple pie
and then i made a uh pecan pie
and then i had pie crust dough left over
so i put it in inside ramekins
and cooked up some quick three berry mix
and made filling for that and baked
those made a little mini pies they were
good
ate those yesterday yeah we had those
left just put whipped cream on them ate
them out of the damn ramekin it was
really good there's so much that's
always bums me out about i mean i love
thanksgiving and i love like these big
feasts and stuff like that but i'm
always like my poor little stomach
it's always like everything looks so
good and i always want to like eat some
of it so i have like one plate and then
i'm just like oh man i just i really
don't feel like i should eat anymore
because i feel kind of sick but then i'm
just like but i want some of this and
that the other thing then i eat another
half plate and then i'm like oh why did
i do that well you work on it slowly
it's like we're gonna stay because i was
like really excited about particularly
the apple pie and i was like oh i'm
gonna get some apple pie and i'm just
like oh my god
now i'm just
yeah i mean maybe like later tonight
later tonight we'll get some i'll have a
piece but right now and we and we ate
like a couple hours ago yeah but i'm
still sitting here going oh
yeah
it's just so much i made this polish
beets
stuff it's like a puree of beets
with a little bit of sugar a little bit
of uh thickening agent in there and a
little bit of
vinegar it's good i like it
that's good on any meat
a little bit of cream in it
made yams too
yeah with marshmallows on top i mean
there was just gravy and rolls and yeah
two different kinds of gravy
turkey gravy and vegetable gravy out of
the damn stockpot
i can't let the i can't let those juices
go away and then the water that i boiled
the
potatoes in i saved all that water and i
used that for the vegetable gravy as a
thickener
yeah you shouldn't waste anything i mean
come on it's all flavor don't waste
anything
that's the thing now i would submit
that we kind of go crazy
on thanksgiving especially and christmas
this year too because honestly
i did it
well
yeah well we made like
i kind of feel like we made a little bit
more food for christmas because
for thanksgiving we actually just bought
pies because we were like [ __ ] it we
don't really want to make pies from
scratch but this year like made three
pies from scratch
so
so it looks like everybody's here
but that's why i mean that's why he made
all the food over the past couple days
and like made it all today and we had
like a big
you know feast this evening so it's like
tomorrow we can just get up and we don't
have to cook anything because they'll be
just you know yeah there'll be leftovers
out the wazoo really won't have to cook
for a week
yeah well you know that's always a plus
just be eating off that [ __ ] for a week
i know
i think all the mashed potatoes are
going to go first because i'm going to
inhale all of you
well everything's multi-purpose you know
what i mean now this goes with anything
this is just multi-purpose
and it's good because i like that i like
the turkey dark meat yeah and you don't
really like it all that much she gets
all dark i get all the dark meat so
that's like really good i like i like
the white meat too it's just that it's
okay just it's just i prefer the white
meat
yeah i mean i like both kinds but
i don't know dark meat to me is just a
little bit better it's just a little
more flavorful
and um
white meat has a tendency to get a
little bit drier although honestly we
don't usually i mean i'm not a cookie
you know how to cook it i mean the the
turkey made i had like mostly dark meat
but then i had a piece of white meat too
just try and it was just like
really really moist so yeah it came out
really good
okay so today is uh
[ __ ]
holiday sidetracks
oh it's like an open lines friday we
could talk about anything
any subject got paranormal unsolved
mysteries just any questions anything
you guys want to talk about we can talk
about the jolly fat man
could talk you know [ __ ] uh we could
talk about mrs fat man this is fat man
yeah that's that's that's that's uh
that's mrs claus
you could talk about anything you want
sorry i'm just i've watched i'm watching
pookie behind you she's back there like
playing with one of her like little
halloween mountains back there
she's rolling on her back fighting or
something
we were telling her before before we
started the show like tom was over there
mixing the drinks and pookie's just
sitting there watching him intently and
i was like is she learning how to be a
bartender
and then i had like a really funny learn
how to miss drinks and everything yeah
then i had like a really funny mental
picture of lil pooky in a little uniform
standing behind a bar like the grenadine
[ __ ] yeah
knows the exact amount of burp
she would be a good bartender
with her little bitty little grandpas
asking if so we want a drink
they've had some guys that have trained
a dog to get to [ __ ] a beer out of the
refrigerator
give me a beer and a [ __ ]
that to me is like hilarious and awesome
at the same time because
it's so i like it because it's
contradictory you're so lazy that you
can't get up and get your own beer but
on the other hand it probably took a
really really long time to train the dog
to do that maybe not maybe not
but
i don't know that's just like really
really funny to me yeah um
i was gonna say something else about
what pookie was doing today but i forgot
what it was
she was doing something like goofy that
was funny
they're already asking me to [ __ ] put
wigs on
it's a little early for that although we
did start a little bit later to be fair
no need for me uh has a request he wants
us to talk about the philadelphia
experiment and any insights we might
have we did a show about that didn't we
also wanted but maybe he didn't hear i
can't remember that much about it to be
honest with you but i'm pretty sure we
did actually do uh
this is getting ready to get on a train
to her parents house there's a feast of
waiting for her around there
and then she's going to get a [ __ ]
slice of all the way there how long does
it take to get there
if it was up to us tom and jim would you
would you mediate alien contact or hold
off all right
okay
so
let's start with the alien contact thing
if aliens wanted to contact us nobody
would be able to stop it there wouldn't
be any mediation they would just uh go
down and start commuting we're going to
talk at you [ __ ] whether you like it
or not they probably already have it
figured out
they know our languages know how we
communicate they probably speak to us
through kind of like an ai avatar avatar
first
probably looked just like a human
they probably wouldn't want any and then
they'd probably show representations of
what they look like if it was possible
so they might be non-physical
you never can't tell
you know they might just be a ghost in a
machine they might be a
a like a soul inside of an internet
somewhere
inside a spaceship
they might not be biological i think it
i think it's more likely that any alien
that would contact us would not be
biological that
it would lean more towards that
something that had conquered by the
limitations of biology
next dimension media says wondering if
you guys have seen bad sport on netflix
love to hear tom's take on the horse
hitman episode no we haven't seen that
actually i haven't even heard about that
the white hit man
horse hit man i don't know that one
yeah that's not uh that's on netflix so
yeah i haven't even heard anything about
that one but uh one of these days we'll
check it out elsa said i'm [ __ ]
starving door-to-door it'll take about
two hours yeah i mean you know what it's
the holidays it's all about indulgence
you don't get to do it
you know the rest of the year so i'm
just like man if you want some pizza
have some
okay so philadelphia experiment
i think the case was a hoax uh the story
can be tr traced back
to a guy i forgot what his name was kind
of had a hispanic name
and uh
he was telling stories or wrote a story
about it
uh uh
yeah i remember yeah i remember i was
talking about that and then they tried
to hold an investigator tried to home in
on that guy and he was very elusive he
was kind of a
skinny prankster maybe like uh
kind of on the autism spectrum
i think he did have a naval background
maybe a couple years in the navy
uh but it was a made-up story
uh
it's a good story though yeah
he was probably inspired by degaussing
ships halls yeah which they do have that
ability they would de-gauze the ship of
a hull or the hull of a ship
so the the compasses would read
correctly
and
you know you have to wrap a bunch of
[ __ ] wires and [ __ ] throw a bunch
of juice down the damn
hull of the ship and try to get the damn
electro electromagnetic charges out of
it or something i don't know exactly how
it's done i'm not an expert on that
but um
that's probably where he got the idea
if
if you may if you could make ships
invisible
it would probably only be invisible to
radar
there's a possibility
where the navy might
might have considered that uh hey maybe
we should have you know maybe it's
possible to cloak a battle carrier group
so if you paint it with radar that you
don't get a return
it's not crazy to see how that
how a story like that could have become
right so because like you said being
invisible to radar is a thing yeah um
you know just the fact that they don't
mean like literally invisible like you
can't see it when you look at it right
that's the two completely different
things
even in the 80s when they were talking
about invisible planes
people were confused between invisible
planes and invisible radar right you
were talking about the f-117 stealth
fighter
it was invisible to radar
yeah it wasn't like wonder woman's
invisible plane
took a while for that but yeah that was
that plane was just a rumor for a while
a bunch of weird [ __ ] about that plane
um
there was a woman
i remember seeing a uh an interview with
her it was back in the very early 80s or
late 70s
i was i remember her doing the
interviews on a on a damn daytime talk
show where she saw a ufo and she drew it
and she said she was walking
she lived in a kind of a remote
area
and she heard a sound and she looked to
her right and coming up she was down
inside a little valley not a big valley
a little valley and
and
what
a plane or not a plane but a ufo
came right over the top of her
of the crest of the hill and flew right
over and she saw it
and she drew it sure she had it
somebody sketch it for there was a whole
investigator there because i know this
is the truth she did see this ufo
and when you looked at it it was flat on
the bottom it was black and it had it
looked like a damn triangle top on it
and lights and things sticking up like
antenna
and you could take that [ __ ] frontal
ant that that picture
that she drew of that ufo
and put it right alongside the frontal
front silhouette of an f-117 fighter and
that's exactly what she saw
she said it was a black triangle that
flew over her
head
stealth fighter
well it was probably nice for her to
find out that she wasn't crazy yeah
and that she wasn't seeing extra
treasure
flew right over top they're like nope
that was a real thing you saw it and she
said it wasn't silent that it made noise
made a whooshing sound you know she said
like it had jets but she said it was a
black triangle and it was diamond shaped
on the front and they drew it against
f-117 it had bright lights on it
and uh yeah
and uh because nobody knew that that
plane existed in the early 70s early 80s
or late 70s early 80s
mary connolly says do you think our pets
know when we listen to scary or terrible
topics
um
yeah they couldn't hear emotion in your
voice they know yeah uh pookie kind of
gets upset if we're like watching a
horror movie that has a lot of screaming
in it yeah she knows um she doesn't
really like that it kind of like
stresses her out some yeah normally she
doesn't really care about stuff that's
on a screen she knows that's not real
yeah um she doesn't usually react to it
mostly what she'll she'll do is like if
we're watching something on the tv she
jumps up in front of it and is like hey
look at me instead of at the tv i did
notice though last night and i told you
about this last night because i said we
need to get the christmas mood right so
we watched die hard obviously because
it's christmas uh then we watched them
up at christmas carol
and then i saw that amazon also had emma
otter's jug band christmas for 1.99 so i
was like oh let's watch that too even
though it was getting kind of late now
when we were watching that
pookie sat on the um the bench at the
end of our bed and watched pretty much
the whole thing
like with wrapped attention i don't know
if it was because the little puppets
little otter puppets kind of look like
her like they were little and fuzzy and
you know and it was kind of it's kind of
like an older show so it wasn't like
real crisp maybe she saw it different
but she just like sat there and watched
the whole thing like especially when
like the little mama otter was like was
on screen and she was like singing and
stuff pookie was like looking right at
it yeah normally she doesn't do that
normally it was a real object it wasn't
animated i think maybe that's what it
was but yeah she looked like a little
animal singing so that's what i thought
like she seemed like she was kind of
really interested in it she um
we we've uh she's been sitting at the
foot of the bed when something some kind
of horror thing happened on a horror
movie and she's turned around and looked
at us remember that yeah like did you
see like somebody else scream or
something like [ __ ] up will happen
like somebody will get chopped up or
something in the movie yeah we're like
it's okay and she'll turn around and be
like is is everything is she all right
[Laughter]
so she definitely does now
i mean she knows if
um like if one of us is upset
you know what i mean she knows she knows
that the tone of voice she gets like
agitated yeah so she does when she knows
yeah yeah yeah she totally does she'd be
checking on her and they should check it
on me you guys mad
[Laughter]
it's just really funny i honestly though
until we were watching emma daughter
last night i've never seen her give that
much sustained attention
to something on the tv before yeah
um but no he he was hoping that there
was something to the uh
the philadelphia experiment
no yeah it could it can the story can be
traced back to a guy who was telling a
story
and they never really interviewed him he
would
he would uh when the when they tried to
track down the origin of the story that
led to him
i think it was back in the 60s that they
isolated it wasn't it the early 60s
is that where they tracked the story i
can't remember now 60s to mid 60s he was
evasive he was hard to find he was he
wasn't making much money he was
traveling from one kind of low rent
dishwasher type job to the next
uh he wasn't dumb though he was uh just
kind of like a
mad scientist type kid
and uh he liked uh paranormal stuff and
ufo stuff he uh had he had in his
possession a bunch of books
uh they found if i remember correctly
they somebody got a hold of a book that
he once owned and he had been scribbling
in the margins a bunch of things and you
know about ufos
so he was in the paranormal scene that's
that's who that story down to now he was
uh
i think he did do time in the navy
but it wasn't on the philadelphia
and then they tracked down the crew of
the philadelphia and there was nothing
to any of that
there was nothing unusual
looks like we were red for a second it's
right over here
[ __ ] no no no no no not already come on
yeah
come on
don't
come on you can do it
i think it's coming it's bad okay it's
coming back it's bad sorry about that we
didn't say it we didn't say anything
important in the middle no
he tracked it down they tracked it down
um you tracked down the crew of the
philadelphia and nothing unusual
happened during the time that they're
talking about and that ship was just
decommissioned
eventually i think it might have been
sold off to another country or it was
dismantled one of the two um
but no there
nothing happened during that time
to that ship
or that crew there aren't any people
missing or anything everything is
accounted for well it was just one of
those things where it was like a story
that kind of got repeated so many times
and people lost track of where it came
from yeah
that's kind of like what we were talking
and i think i was talking about this a
little bit on the christmas show too
where we were talking about the
mistletoe bride story
that i'm not saying that it's completely
impossible that that didn't happen like
that woman you know getting stuck in the
trunk or whatever but
the stories that came out about it later
were probably just based on that poem
that somebody had written which may or
may not have been based on something or
may have just been a [ __ ] story and i
just think like the you know the the
source of it kind of became lost over
the years as it got more popular
uh just pepper is asking do you think if
aliens were friendly that there would be
a bias against them do you think it
would change social biases in our
current culture friendly is in not
trying to conquer earth and subjugate
humanity
i don't i didn't get i didn't understand
the question what was the question again
if they're friendly what we become
friendly no did you do you think there
would be biases against them
no
no it would depend you know what bias i
mean what's she talking about you say
would be great would we be racist
against aliens is that what she's asking
you know what i think it would probably
depend on
i don't know what the aliens how
different they were from us what they if
they looked really different i mean for
whatever reason i thought of district 9
yeah where they kind of became an
underclass because they looked like big
insects yeah um
you know so obviously if something
looked more like something that humans
don't like
then it would probably they would
probably have a harder time of it than
if they looked
you know more noticeably human-like yeah
another thing about them and out of
district 9 is that they weren't very
human remember that they said they were
yeah they were like in a cast system
some of them were kind of just robotic
they didn't really know much of anything
they just knew how to fix the ship
uh then other ones were more intelligent
they weren't all the same in there
remember yeah the one the one that had
the little tiny child
alien child and they were trying to
extract some kind of fuel from its fuel
pellet so they could leave
um
remember that he was smarter than all
the rest of them and he abandoned a lot
of them because they were just kind of
like
chattel you know
the other aliens because we assume that
just because it's a
you would assume that just because it's
a successful
space faring civilization you would
assume that they were all intelligent
which is consuming a lot humans have
been to space too but most of them are
idiots yeah so i'm sure it's probably
the same with any other planet no it
might be even more
it might be even more extreme than that
that there are basically are brain bugs
and then they're damn brawn bugs and
just workers
and some of them might be just insects
you know but they're controlled through
you know chemicals or telepathy and they
just work you know on some state
spaceship but they're not intelligent
really
but there might be like a a hive mind or
there might be one you know some of the
ones at the top might be kind of like
queen ants or drone ants and and there
they might have a superior intellect
because really it's when you think about
it
it's not in a species advantage
advantage for everyone to be intelligent
that'll cause a lot of problems there
are too many chiefs and not enough
indians
it would be more efficient probably if
it was kind of more like an ant colony
where a couple of them are real
intelligent
and they just the rest of them are all
expendable but they have a very high
birth rate
and they may understand technology
but it doesn't matter if the if the
other ones die
there's not much to them and they're
many of them are born every year and
they don't live long anyway maybe they
only live a couple months or a couple
years
but they don't need to know anything
maybe they're just uh they're just
instructed to do things just kind of
through telepathy
or
you know chemical signals like ants you
know see all that kind of stuff
fascinates me like insect communication
like how ants and bees and stuff like
that communicate with one another that's
like really fascinating yeah you might
have you might have some kind of
alien ant if that's what you want to
call it it's [ __ ] big you know bigger
than a person
inside a spaceship [ __ ] doing
advanced electronics but it doesn't even
understand what it's doing it's just
doing what it's told to do
you know just
that would actually probably be
better for a species survival
it worked with ants and it worked with
bees and things
yeah david robertson is saying he was in
the navy for a long time and said and
said about the philadelphia experiment
that yeah it was from degaussing that's
where that was yeah
oop went right again
come on don't
don't please don't
i thought nobody was going to be online
today because it's christmas eve
i guess the traffic's heavy maybe it is
i'm not really sure because i was kind
of thinking oh it's christmas eve people
are going to be like doing other [ __ ]
rather than being online but maybe not
maybe maybe everybody's like online
watching christmas movies and [ __ ] now
um the whole thing about alien conquest
is actually quite kind of silly when you
think about it
if you have a space-faring
civilization it could travel between
stars
that's a [ __ ] mighty leap that takes
a lot of technology to do that why the
hell would you
conquer an inhabited planet when there
are so many raw materials just out there
just for the taking
you know
that's just that was like that's like
part of the problem with
l ron hubbard's
[ __ ] battlefield earth he had these
corporate aliens that [ __ ] conquer
the earth so they could get gold bars of
gold
i think there's gold everywhere [ __ ]
everywhere in the universe this damn
supernova nova goes off and [ __ ]
blows out pieces of gold the size of
planets
the shit's out there just floating
around
so yeah it's like go get that yeah gold
wouldn't be worth any wouldn't be worth
anything to a space traveling
space-faring universe uh space uh
civilization gold just be everywhere
you'd be able to get anything easily
be out and damn asteroid belts are just
floating around
another thing that people don't realize
is uh
you see all those stars out there in the
universe they all have planets
and according to surveys
like a lot of them have earth light like
planets which are earth-type planets
especially when they're around an
earth-type star
i think they said [ __ ] one-quarter of
them seem to have earth type planets
which is a lot that's like might as well
might as well just say all of them have
it that's just those numbers are huge
when you think of that you might as well
just say yeah they all have earth-like
planets
now whether or not it's habitable or
inside a zone inside a habitable zone
they're saying yes it's in a habitable
zone but you know it might be too cold
or too hot
but none of that matters the terrestrial
type planets are [ __ ] common
for every one of those stars you see
there's like three or four other ones
you don't see these little damn brown
dwarfs and those possibly could have
habitable planets so there's [ __ ] tons
of those stars around you don't even see
those
now
for all of those that you don't see
there's 20 times that numbers and
[ __ ] rogue planets which are planets
like the earth or [ __ ] even jupiter
that somehow during the formation of the
dam so their solar system they got slung
out
so they're just flying around
a planet without a star just went off in
a random direction until it hit
something or falls into another stone
but probably didn't hit anything
so there were probably planets in our
solar system during the early formation
some of them got [ __ ] slung out
because they weren't in a stable orbit
um
there's there's a possibility that
you know this uh there was one guy that
went through the [ __ ] he
did the damn
computations and said that there's a
possibility
possibility that some of those rogue
planets could be could be habitable
because
some planets generate enough heat just
on their own from their cores to where
even if there was no sun
it would be frozen at it it would be
frozen maybe in some spots but
it would probably have zones on it where
it might be about 50 60 degrees that's
warm enough for life
you know
especially if there's a bunch of
volcanic activity
or if there's [ __ ] geysers underneath
the ocean so there's all kinds of
possibilities
now i think it's unlikely that there'd
be life on a rogue planet
because the rogue planet probably goes
through a lot of [ __ ] and it's in its
[ __ ] life
but who knows it might have enough
pressure and enough nuclear
dam
activity in its core to where it would
keep it from freezing i don't think the
earth would the earth would freeze
without the sun
but i think just like in that movie we
saw yeah
but if it was if the earth was more
massive and it had more nuclear type
materials in the in its core it would it
could make it could generate enough heat
to keep itself from freezing over in
certain circumstances
and then you say well if it had that
much mass
uh you know you'd be crushed from the
gravitational forces not really the
bigger a [ __ ] the the planet is
the less the force of gravity is at its
surface because the surface is further
away from the center there's a dem
there's a dam uh what do you call it
there's a whole theorem to [ __ ]
dictate that of yeah it might be a very
massive planet but it's so big
that at its surface
the gravitational pull really isn't all
that great
which is that's that's another amazing
thing
i thought it was just sheer mass that
dictated that it does not
size has a lot to do with it too
blaster one says anyone heard of the
russian sleep experiment yes
uh we did a show about that as well
um and that is also that's another one
that um
was actually started out as a fictional
story
and then
got picked up and people forgot where
the source came from so they thought
that it really happened but uh it's just
a fiction it's a good story but uh yeah
it's fictional uh tammy says you two are
way better than spending time with my
husband's family
[Laughter]
well thank you well yeah you know i know
the holidays are fun but yeah like
sometimes you gotta deal with like
[ __ ] you know family members you're
not really crazy about it's like you
know we've all been there
um you know
and let's see tammy says um yeah i know
holidays are rough without my family my
daughter lives in california my mom's in
pennsylvania and i'm in virginia
yeah i mean at least i got to see my mom
and my sister and them like a few weeks
ago so that's good because i don't
really get to see them all that often
but i don't know i do kind of miss the
old days when my grandma was alive and
we'd have the big thing at christmas eve
and everybody would go over there in the
same shirt i know i just realized that
that's actually not the same shirt it's
not this it's not quite the same it's
not quite the same shirt this one's
color in color and it has like a couple
different things about it
but
and my titties are bigger
your titties are bigger
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
the topic is open open lines
whatever whatever you want i mean just
like every other show that we do pretty
much there was uh
somebody else asked some stuff earlier
we never got around to answering it um
what
did we lost connection again a little
bit
i don't think it's still green it was
just me i guess yeah i didn't i didn't
turn red it was just me
i didn't turn red i've been green the
whole thing people asked some questions
and i didn't we didn't get to actually
answer answer it well sometimes people
are asking them quicker than we can
they're going to be then we can answer
you ask them questions again and we'll
get to them people
uh what are we drinking i'm drinking a
uh she took a screwdriver and i'm
drinking a
tequila sunrise
dj maniac says my brother sent me two
blu-rays for christmas little shop of
horrors the director's cut nice yeah and
nothing but trouble i remember that
movie
being really [ __ ]
weird
but i can't really remember much of what
happened in it we got a super chat
oh we did oh okay oh i scrolled back up
okay well you okay there we go thank you
very very much can't stay long but happy
housewarming and merry christmas thank
you so much merry christmas to you as
well thank you very much
yes we're having a good like i said
we're sitting here like trying to digest
yeah after
i'm actually i'm actually glad that we
pushed it to seven instead of six
because we did it we ate at five and i
was just kind of like oh so i'm glad i'm
not doing the show at six because like
my stomach started and i was like really
really full
um
you know what i'm saying
um but yes what uh what was i talking
about oh
so
like i mentioned earlier when we were
watching we were watching christmas [ __ ]
last night right tom says well we gotta
watch die hard so i was like okay fine
so we watch die hard which actually you
can watch for free on
uh imdb tv like if you have amazon prime
you can it has ads but it's not really
that big deal
so we watch that and then for whatever
reason i was like well we need to watch
muppet christmas carol now which you had
never seen right even though michael
caine is in it i had actually forgotten
i love the muppets but i had actually
forgotten
how faithful an adaptation that was yeah
it's good
i think i had seen it it's just i forgot
about it what year was that 92
i was in the army at that time yeah for
some reason it did kind of look familiar
michael caine knocks it out of the park
does a great job as end of ebenezer
scrooge
yeah one of the best i mean one of the
best scrooges there have been a lot i
mean yeah honestly and i like george c
scott uh particularly as well but and
it's a faithful telling of it it's good
it is there's like some little funny
muppet [ __ ] in there too but not as much
as you might think
it's close to the original yeah they
added little songs
yeah and like all the all the little
songs are good and [ __ ] like that and
then after that like i said we were
scrolling through and then for you know
the the little recommended stuff came up
and i was remember i was talking about
emma daughter's jug band christmas yeah
uh the other day like we were talking
about and i was like oh i want to see
that again because i was you know a
little kid
last time i saw it maybe not a little
kid but
i probably saw it when i was a teenager
but i kind of wanted to see that again
and that was like i forgot i thought
that was only like 20 minutes long but
it's not it's like an hour
and the songs in that are good too i
think paul williams did the songs for
that which i didn't know at the time
yeah all the music i was commenting on
those old programs with the muppets how
much better
quality the music was
and how much better the writing was
um
with the exception of some of those
pixar
animated ones are pretty good too most
of the pixar ones are pretty amazing
pretty good yeah um i really like now
there's a lot of the newer ones that i
have yet to see
probably my favorite oh probably my
favorite pixar is actually probably
monsters inc
i like the one with the damn little
princess chick
the little princess yeah the little
barbarian princess jake what was that
brave brave that was pretty good
remember that yeah that's right right
the little scott the little scottish
braves
i like that one you'd probably like a
lot of pixar movies actually
we were watching we liked the toy story
movies i like the toy story ones we were
watching those on um
amc our emc app
you know you know uh
during the day we would go down to amc
theaters
we could watch three of them a week so
we'd run out of them on some months we
watch those pixar ones it's funny
because
some of the animated like pixar
was like some of the best movies of that
of that month well yeah where's the was
the cartoon ones i call them cartoons
they're not really they're they're
[ __ ]
video game animation type deals but that
brave was good
and then they were showing the
it was showing that it was funny because
this grown man grown man's [ __ ]
watching this flicker we're seeing uh
the the it's a good thing i was with you
or everybody might think you're a sexual
predator
like a [ __ ] child
the damn
trailer to uh frozen two frozen two and
i said man that looks good
i haven't seen the first one
you know what i don't think i've seen
the first one all the way through either
which is music and [ __ ] as culturally
ubiquitous as that [ __ ] movie is just
skating along and making ice and [ __ ]
that was like that'd be like something
back back in high school [ __ ] in
brazil we drop acid and go [ __ ]
go to the movies and watch some [ __ ]
like that just be totally lost in it
thank you janet good job that's also
very nice of you have a great holiday
season thank you we're right back at you
happy holidays christmas presents oh
it's so nice i was gonna say too like i
was gonna i don't think she's here but i
was gonna say thank you to sophie
because she sent
me a very nice uh donation today as well
yes it was
and i sent her a nice gift though she's
gonna open it tomorrow she kind of knows
what they are she just doesn't know what
they look like
because that's boots
that's boots yeah
but uh
yeah oh he said that he'd send us the
dvd of nothing but trouble if we review
it okay i'd be kind of curious to see it
i kind of rem i don't even remember
we got a backlog was dan aykroyd in that
yeah
we got a [ __ ] someone turned into a
monster i don't remember we got a [ __ ]
ton of movies people have sent us over
the years that we never got got around
to i remember which ones we haven't seen
though we gotta we gotta catch up on
them it's just i know i'm so i'm so
disorganized what happened was that we
got like 50 of them in one month
and we got overwhelmed let's go damn
so we only went for like the ones that
were uh
the ones that popped out at us clicking
i got collateral twice wasn't that
collateral yeah
i got two collaterals
we still haven't done
it we still haven't done sexy beast
either and you'd probably i've seen that
before but you probably really like it
yeah i really like all this kind of like
british crime yeah i gotta set all the
all the [ __ ] ones that the viewers
sent that uh we haven't watched yet i
gotta set them aside i gotta make them a
pile of them we'll get through them
yeah we will we'll get through them yeah
i had and i came up with a bunch more
that i forgot i had because they were in
the attic of the old house yeah and i
kind of want to do some of those too
like i have 24-hour party people and i
have chronos uh the first camera el toro
movie okay i thought you talked about
the old 50s horror movie no no
um yeah there's like i think i've a
couple other dario argento ones like
stendall syndrome and stuff i have
revengers tragedy i have all kind of
stuff
so i might get around and i still
haven't done i still am gonna do like a
big
super cuts of all the twin peaks some
reason my [ __ ] keeps pausing but it
doesn't show it as pause and like it's
been green the whole time yeah mine's
it's nice to see why
because you're it was did you forget to
turn down your i'm gonna no i gotta re
voted i was in the past
tom's stuck in the past yeah
yeah but yeah i just i don't know like
it's if i don't get too
[ __ ] drunk tonight so i was gonna you
know what i was gonna go to pluto tv
today
and i kind of figured if i went to the
mst or the rifftrax channel then they'd
be showing like all christmas ones but
they weren't
i was like you know i'm not and i like
all of them i'm just saying that it
would have been cool if they'd have done
you know if they could have done the the
christmas episodes of mst or the all the
rifftrax shorts and stuff that would
have been cool elsa just said merry
christmas on messenger she said that she
wants to hear the whole
thing for the whole billy idol christmas
album i [ __ ] got that i got the whole
billy idol christmas album
listen to it on cd it's great
dj maniac says 24 hour party people you
can turn off after the first hour yeah i
mean i i love that movie but after the
joy division stuff is over and it goes
to happy mondays and the rave stuff
that's not you know that's not as
interesting to me obviously um i mean
it's still good but
i mean definitely the first half is way
way better
uh tammy says a cute christmas movie i
love is lost christmas with eddie izzard
oh you know what i don't i've never seen
that
i like to try to see everything with him
in it because he's awesome
but
uh yeah i don't think i've seen that
actually so i'm gonna have to like i'm
gonna have to look that up i like so
much christmas stuff i gotta watch i'm
just gonna
i mean you know we re-watched stuff last
night but
well last year last year because we did
um
christmas horror matinees i think all
the week of christmas so we actually got
a lot of the good christmas horror
movies
reviewed and like out of the way like we
did black christmas we did
christmas horror story we did better
watch out
um
we did
silent night deadly night too i think
we did that weird ass french one
code
code noel or what the [ __ ] was that
movie called that was [ __ ] weird
i lowered my uh
data quality picture quality so it
should
should be okay
okay maybe that's what maybe it was your
fault yeah it was trying to run at 720.
i put it
no need for me too says santa claus
conquers the martians mst 3k yearly
watch yeah i watch it pretty much every
year at least that one and
the
uh the mst3k santa claus the mexican one
with pitch in it
and last year i think i watched both of
those and the newer one
with jonah ray
uh the christmas that almost wasn't
they're doing for the new season which
isn't going to be
uh finished until next year
they're doing a christmas episode but i
can't remember what movie they're doing
because that was one of the things that
on their um the thing they do on
thanksgiving the turkey day marathon
they came in and said what all the
movies they were gonna do like for next
year are
so
they had so it was a good uh it was a
good combination it seemed like they had
a gamer one in there i think they had an
el santo one in there
and then they had like maybe like a spy
one i can't remember all the ones they
were that they did
but they were gonna do a christmas movie
and they're doing a halloween episode
which they never did before
which is weird now that i'm thinking
about it they never like a halloween
special
no need for me too said not a fan of the
newer ones that much yeah i kind of feel
i get that um i like them though but
it's it's definitely a little bit of a
different
vibe
and so it took some getting used to
especially the different voices uh for
the bots gotta watch christmas
chronicles man
yeah we still gotta watch christmas
chronicles yeah i'll watch the first one
and second one i don't care yeah yeah
well maybe we can watch that tonight
because we've seen that a lot russ
we just now we watched the second one
last year right yeah
i didn't know i didn't like that one as
much but it's not as fun it's not as
good as the first one but
what are you gonna do but it's still
pretty good
yeah dj maniac says just go watch
control instead yeah i agree with that i
don't i actually don't have
that on blu-ray i don't think
but that was also like a really really
great movie that was kind of mostly
based on um
deborah curtis's
book
right touching from a distance that was
about anchors which i have back there
somewhere but i think that's what that
movie was mostly based around so it's
most about her
uh perceptions of him
and as well as like interviews with
other band members members and stuff oh
another thing that somebody told me we
need to watch is there's a newish
documentary about the velvet underground
i can't remember what streaming service
it's on
but it sounds pretty good so we need to
see that as well
uh
no need for me to kirk cameron says
it saves christmas
oh my god i you know what
if i was more of a masochist i might sit
and watch that i did i did listen to the
god-awful movies
breakdown of it
and it sounds atrocious
but it sounds so atrocious that i almost
kind of want to watch it
i don't know if i want it
it's a it's a it's an uber christian
christian like christmas movie with kirk
cameron in it i don't know him he used
to be like on uh what the [ __ ] sitcom
was he on in the 80s he was like really
really popular what the [ __ ] show was
that
i'll remember it a minute got a super
chat
thank you zach
merry christmas boos and ghouls from
that angle tom looks like spongebob in
the episode where he gets the inflatable
muscle arms
i don't know if that's good
it's coming from zach
zack's fantasizing
and then tj maniac said i'd watch kirk
cameron shuts the [ __ ] up about jesus
but he hasn't made it yet
that's a good one oh my god that's
[ __ ] weird
right he did a lot of movies like well
kirk cameron
he kind of went the same route as like
kevin sorbo and like some other actors
that were kind of like b-list actors but
then now then they went all
fundamentalist and now the only things
they can be in our christian movies but
they're they're the a-listers of the
fundamentalists well yeah because they
were like the only [ __ ] that were
even remotely famous before they went i
cut didn't melissa joan heart go that
way too although i think she's still in
normal movies every now and then here's
the thing man i've done this before
growing pains thank you that's what that
show was called i got nothing against
christian movies or christians i would i
would love to make a christian movie
mine would be revelations and it would
be with all the cg [ __ ] it would be the
book of revelations it'd be scary as
[ __ ] and it would be like right out of
the it would have a beast coming out of
the ocean [ __ ] the [ __ ] of babylon
and have all that and it would
it would just be like an acid trip you
know be like i don't know i think i
could i think i could make a [ __ ]
badass flick it would be a trip
the problem with christian movies is the
writing
they just don't know how to write
it there's a few exceptions
darren aronowski's [ __ ] noah was
badass i like that yeah but he's an
atheist as far as i know it doesn't
matter no i'm just saying that it
doesn't matter
atheists make better christian movies
it's the writing
it's
the talent isn't there
i guess the talent and the experience
isn't there in the christian independent
film scene
you think that it would you think that
maybe
there would be talent but i mean you
think at least one person would be able
to you think that rising up out of the
damn [ __ ] pile would be at least a
couple of good ones
um
you might say well mel gibson because he
did passion of the christ yeah but he
did normal movies he mostly does normal
movies yeah
you know [ __ ] mel gibson can can make
good movies
i thought i loved apocalypto
um
it just and you could say in a way that
might have been a christian movie not
really the conquistadors show up in the
end
but um
yeah and then there was that one that
the only one that was well actually
there was there was two of them i
remember
there was a christian movie about the
rapture that [ __ ] freaked the hell
out of me
been a long time i remember the name of
it i think it was just called the
rapture or rapture or might have been
you thought people were crazy and it
turned out it was actually happening
yeah i remember that that one was weird
wasn't mimi rogers in that i think so
i think yeah that was actually that was
a good movie right it can be done we've
talked about this before it can be done
all right it's the writing it just
doesn't get done all that often for
whatever reason and then that bill
paxton flick where they were frailty
frailty killing them demons that was
[ __ ] awesome and that was a christian
movie
yeah it was i mean yeah really good it
and it's in what made those movies good
was the writing the writing and the
story they knew how to manipulate you as
the audience they were also [ __ ] up
your expectations of things
there was a horror elements in them and
horror and supernatural elements but
they were in
they were they they were sticking close
to the christian source material as some
of the [ __ ] that chris that is in the
christian source material would be like
a horror movie if it was actually
happening
i kind of feel like the problem with a
lot with a lot of yeah you know you know
christian centered entertainment that's
geared toward that audience is that they
don't really want to go full-on horror
right and but and i think that's a
mistake right they wanted to be
light-hearted and fun and i guess and
fun for the whole family we've now just
clipped the balls off of christianity
because the most the most interesting
parts of christianity are the [ __ ]
that's kind of wrath of god scary kind
of [ __ ]
and really that's kind of the message
you know [ __ ] it's got to be like
this because the lord's coming back and
you all are going to get punished and
[ __ ] then there's the antichrist
there's that even though some not all
not all the christian churches had the
book of revelations
not all like you know eastern orthodox
is not an apocalyptic version of
christianity it doesn't have
uh revelations
um but that doesn't matter the western
christian audience has revelations it is
an apocalyptic christian sec
cult basically they're all cults i don't
care how big they are all religions are
cults they're just
it just gets big enough to where you
have to recognize it as a religion but
even the cults are being recognized a
cult is just a small sect that's all it
is it's not it's not a derogatory
uh uh thing to be said it's just that
everything springs from cults cults just
get big
and everything that people think is is
canon
and everything that christians and and
other religions what they think is
orthodoxy
actually all springs from heresy
because when though when those beliefs
were brand new they were under attack by
other sexes and that's heresy you can't
believe in that but over time they
became orthodoxy
so everything is heresy that's where it
starts
so
in christian tradition and tradition of
all these other
religions you can basically say and do
whatever you want you can reboot it you
can reinterpret it because people have
been doing it for thousands of years
like people will attack
mormonism in the book of mormon saying
oh man that's that's heresy that's just
something made up that didn't happen
man that is just like none of that
you're like why are you getting picky
about this one particular thing right
this the the the mormon stories are
equally as historical as the christian
stories because neither one really
happens that way it's just
that
writing religions is an art form and
they are written and they're created
just ask el ron hubbard
and that's the way they all the way
these religions are born or
there's personalities and groups behind
them that are writing this stuff or
compiling it
from people who really wrote it before
them they'll just be like dudes who are
into supercomp superhero comics they'd
like oh man we're gonna have [ __ ]
superman [ __ ] one through thirty but
now we're not having the superman that
he wrote we're not going to put that in
there we don't like that that isn't that
doesn't [ __ ] discuss
you know you know [ __ ] uh kryptonite
you know or is this you know this so
they were always picking and choosing
what would end up in the holy books
what are they saying thank you zach it's
interesting how most christian movies
are also badly acted and have that ugly
as [ __ ] network tv looked at yeah yeah
you don't have to you don't have to use
every light on set yeah um if you have i
don't have a subscription to this
personally but in case you didn't know
there is a christian uh netflix and it's
called called pureflix uh because they
can't think of their own original name
yeah and uh even the logo kind of looks
the same except the background is blue
instead of red yeah and um this one dude
david a.r white
as far as i know he is either like the
main owner of pureflix or one of the
main owners and he writes and stars in a
[ __ ] ton of shows on there because they
don't just have movies they have like
their own sitcoms and everything and
pretty much every like from what i can
determine from like other channels i
watch that cover it
everything on there is like a ripoff of
some secular stuff yeah like they're
trying to make their own kind of lamer
christian version yeah of it like
without swearing or booze or writing a
christian version of tolkien
you know or let's do a christian version
of walking dead i mean well yeah so it's
just like pretty much any um you know
any sitcom that has any kind of like
buzz about it like parks and rec or
something like that they've had they
have like a christian version of it
which is considerably considerably
shittier but what i was going to say
about kirk cameron was that he's done i
mean kirk cameron saves christmas i
think is the is the most uh
the one that's like the that people like
to make fun of the most because it
sounds like the most batshit crazy to be
honest with you um but he's also made a
couple other ones there was one
that was called fireproof
where he plays a fireman who has a porn
addiction
and it's kind of mostly just like a
drama about how you should be nice to
your wife or something i don't know um
like i said that was another one that i
saw on uh god-awful movies they do a lot
of kirk cameron movies on there uh and
their breakdowns are like super funny i
mean the the breakdowns they do are
sometimes longer than the actual movie
just because they there's three of them
and they just like talk about it so much
but the ones that they they did kirk
cameron saves christmas as well
but uh yeah so any of those and any of
the like uh creationist movies are
always comedy gold i find yeah
yeah zach i think the problem with with
christian product is that uh
the the market that they're selling to
is very milk toast
yeah there's so much they can't do
there's so much that they can't do
they're they're boxed in yeah they don't
want to offend any of them so what you
end up with is like a very like hallmark
like hallmark channel type [ __ ] it's so
so bland and so
toned down and watered down it's just
you're not watching anything and all the
movies were kind of like that and
there's kind of like
a fake air about them like i know you
they i know you i know your church is
making you watch this movie so let's
pretend like we're all having fun that's
kind of like that kind of vibe you know
what i'm talking about yeah i know this
isn't the movie that you really want to
be watching but we're going to do a
christian version but since you're not
really allowed
to watch another one there's kind of
like that
it's kind of like they're talking to a
captive audience
yeah so it's kind of like instead of
having good cheese you're having like a
cheese product yeah yeah
and it's because they have to be within
a small narrow framework of
acceptability yeah i mean there's a lot
of topics they can't really talk about
there's they have a very specific agenda
right and everything that they put
across has to conform to that agenda
right which is funny because uh when
christianity burst upon the roman scene
according to romans that first [ __ ]
contacted their comments was that it was
just this bizarre
belief
about some criminal who got crucified
and came back to life and
they eat his blood and
they eat his flesh and drink his blood
which would be the roman interpretation
they just said it's just a a whole bunch
of strange
uh uh what they call them superstitions
okay and then they did weird stuff
evidently you know like said [ __ ] it you
have to kill me i'm not bowing to the
emperor's statue so i don't know if that
actually happened i think that this
whole thing about being thrown to the
lions
that's christian church saying that
um
there aren't any contemporary records
that are commentary about christians
being thrown to lions and
being burned down appian way that was
evidently fraudulent uh the romans
didn't seem to
um take much interest in the christians
i mean they had so many religions and
they didn't persecute people based on
religion i think it was something made
up afterwards
to make christians seem like they were
personal
before before rome officially became
christian that's that's the only reason
why that that particular roman religion
survives is because the roman empire
adopted it
you know
and it took a long time for it to really
stick in in the roman culture because
they had so many of them
straw dog 78 said kirk cameron actually
attacks his evil porn ridden computer
with an axe in the movie
like it's the computer's fault that you
went to a porn site yeah kirk cameron
that wasn't your computer doing that
[Laughter]
oh my god how is this porn getting on my
computer i did it
it's funny how they're
constantly stuck in those old 1960s
problems and 70s problems of the evils
of porn
you know i'm like yeah i hate to tell
you but like that that horse is left
that way why are you worried about that
decades ago yeah
that horse has left the bar in a long
time ago
that horse left the barn went across the
world went into outer space yeah
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
yeah uh
yeah because dan michael said zachary
tom's right because evil is sexier
it's bad but that's how it is yeah well
yeah like i kind of feel like as i said
they have a very particular agenda they
want to get across and
they only have
you know they're really kind of cutting
themselves off at the knees because they
don't have there's here there's all
these topics or all these viewpoints
that they can't address whereas somebody
who was coming from a more secular
standpoint
could write from any number of different
perspectives or could write about any
number of different topics could even
take on
like uh you know if you're writing a
short story and you were like well i
don't believe this particular thing but
would it be interesting if i wrote as a
character who did believe that like you
can do that kind of stuff but they won't
do that so it comes across as just like
really really
limited and you know and like i said too
it kind of feels like they don't
you'd think that at least they'd have
like some people that worked on crews
and stuff like that that knew how
to make movies i mean from what i've
seen of cause like i said i wan like god
awful movies has stuff about it and uh
nick deramio he has a channel where
sometimes he does stuff on pureflix
because he has a pure flick subscription
just for shits and giggles and so like
sometimes he'll watch some crazy [ __ ] on
there so i was watching some of his
breakdowns of uh some of the sitcoms and
they look like ass i mean they look like
it looks like somebody i was gonna say
it looks like somebody shot it on their
cell phone but it doesn't even look that
good
um it just looks terrible like the
lighting is so bad and just a lot of
them are shot
in what is very obviously
um they shoot it in front of a green
screen like the actors and then put it
on top of you know they buy some stock
footage of like corporate office and
like drop it in the background and it
looks really [ __ ]
i'm not really sure like why they think
not
in this day and age you can't get away
with that anymore youtube videos have
higher production quality than that
seriously i don't think it's just a
hamming themselves in thing like you
were talking about well that's one thing
it's just
they ignore their best material
you know what i mean their best
materials in old testament and new
testament scriptures but they won't talk
about that
for some reason those aren't the movies
like why don't they do something about
the book of daniel
about that damn big old statue with the
clay feet and everything and the guys
having a damn
vision of [ __ ] empires that have
passed and some to come it's kind of
like revelations and that's got some
spooky imagery in it and you could do
it would be that a movie like that would
be a damn trip and then you could have
it kind of hooked up where it's like
part
part uh um documentary like man who saw
tomorrow you know what i mean with some
of it's narrated by ursa wells or
something you know like this is gonna
happen you know [ __ ] that movie
[ __ ] the man who saw tomorrow scared
the [ __ ] out of me when i was a kid
scared the [ __ ] out of me even though
those quatrains are all taken out of
damn order and they're all [ __ ] missed
together and mashed together about five
but when you're a little kid you don't
know that and you have like [ __ ] you
have [ __ ] what's his name like
telling you the [ __ ] you're right or
something well orson welles [ __ ] like
his somber very serious tones
and uh yeah you're like a little kid
seeing that going holy [ __ ]
the world's gonna end
but you know
book of revelations would make a great
movie i could probably get three movies
out of that like a trilogy
of the imagine that
well [ __ ] man i i could even see you
could even do like a whole i i could
even think of like a lot of product
tie-ins you could do for that kind of
[ __ ] you could have like a line of toys
in it yeah
all
right
or collectibles showing all this imagery
of scripture you know what i mean a
[ __ ]
big old blazing flaming backgrounds
looking you know the beast rising up out
of the oceans and the [ __ ] the seven
heads and all the [ __ ] the [ __ ] of
babylon and then it goes on and then the
angels [ __ ] make him eat the little
book and then they open up the damn un
un break the seal and the lamb unbreaks
the seal and [ __ ] you know was what
falls out this guy [ __ ] stars fall
out of the sky you know imagine that
[ __ ] you're outside and stars fall out
of the sky land on the ground you're
picking them up
okay ow
and then a [ __ ] tries to sell
one you know what happens then
you know
but they didn't know how big a star was
hey this cool [ __ ] fella this guy yeah
give me five dollars and the stars have
fallen from this guy
and every time something
hefty happens it zooms into
i guess reality and there's characters
and those stories stories happen and
then they see they're in rome and they
see the stars falling from the sky you
know just
it's just a trip you know you can put it
throughout different times and then you
know the [ __ ] antichrist comes and
tries to make the one world government
where you have to accept the mark if you
wanted to damn buy and sell and trade
and
and you know
and you actually but you know every time
it it goes into like a scene that's
supposed to be like something actually
happening on earth it can't be long it
can only be like 10 or 15 yeah because
that's the boring bits because that's
boring well
there's no continuity amongst characters
right so every time you go in it's got
to be years apart so some of the shit's
happening in heaven and some of the
shits happen in earth and you have to
make the transition
you know it's in heaven because that's
what it says in scripture and then it
shows you what's happening in earth you
have to you have to write it it has to
flow really cool like a music video
almost
zach says imagine if there was a
religion based netflix for scientology
at which point sidequest hero says wait
they have one uh they do have it i think
don't they run a television channel from
their base outside la i know they were
always trying to recruit us when i was
in film school
yeah
what's funny is that they bought a
television studio
yeah a television studio they don't
broadcast
well like i said you can still make like
youtube videos you can make like youtube
and tick tock videos and [ __ ] now do
that [ __ ] with a youtube channel
thank you again zach
it also seems to be uniquely us
christianity that has this weird
outdated thinking on issues that no one
cares about anymore and acts so up its
own ass yeah i mean at least from what i
know uh of europe in general even though
that a lot of people that are nominally
christian they don't really give that
much of a [ __ ] about it i think it's
mostly that way here too um
well
christians mostly
yeah but you do have um a significant
minority of really loud mouth people
about it trying to like get all up in
everyone's business
you know yeah well it's better than it
was for sure but you know i still i
still think that's still around
yeah side quest hero said i went to the
la film school right around the corner
from the hollywood building
how interesting that the little
scientologists are toddling over there
to the film schools and trying to get
people to work on their [ __ ] that's like
pretty funny
[ __ ] science house [ __ ]
scientologist
when you know all the backstory and all
the people involved in david miscavige
and just the way that they do [ __ ]
[ __ ]
where's shelley
and all that stuff you know
it's just funny that they that they want
to make movies
though this is the deal though they
actually don't want to make movies they
don't want to do those videos they're
being told to do that by miss cabbage
they have all this money that they've
been building out of what they call
whales it's these people that [ __ ]
donate a bunch of money to them
and they have to do something with it
they can't just keep it in a bank
or they'll lose their tax exemption
status so they have to [ __ ] buy
things that
are religious religious based
uh they're like charities they can't
make money so that make making those
movies is just a way of flushing money
down the toilet and making some cheap
[ __ ] crazy looking product even
though everything that they do is
supposedly kind of high quality and
compared to other cults it is high
quality looking stuff but it's just
crazy because none of it makes any money
none of it really get none of it gains
any following
like it doesn't help expand the church
but that's not the idea the idea was
they had all this money they had to get
rid of
and then they'll have all these books
and videos and they'll just put them up
on shelves in these empty buildings
where it looks like a down book store
it's nothing but scientology books would
be one person sitting at a desk and a
book hasn't been sold out of there in
[ __ ] decades
and then they changed the books out all
the time new covers
it's like it's like a potemkin village
like something out of north korea
or old soviet union if you know the
potemkin villages a fake village that's
well that's all
scientology is it's all just artificial
well they want to look kind of like yeah
impressive and [ __ ]
grant there's hamburger not all serious
christians are pious boring mundanes oh
yeah not not by a long stretch uh some
examples of great talents johnny cash
bono matthew mcconaughey jrr tolkien and
alice cooper believe it or not
uh yeah and dan michael says christians
are now only 40 of us at best so we'll
see how things go
most of them are um cultural christians
though
yeah they don't go to church all the
time they're not really worried about it
yeah i mean just like anything else it's
always like going to be a minority
that's going to be really really
hardcore about it i'm a mythicist i
think it's all mythology that doesn't
mean that doesn't mean i reject it
though i think i think mythology is very
useful
uh it kind of bolts it it helps you
build up morale
to keep faith in the future uh the
imagery is really cool i don't think any
of that stuff's literally true though
but i don't
i think it's silly to [ __ ] hate
religions because well why aren't you
hating [ __ ]
ancient
greco-roman traditions though well
they're cursing zeus why aren't you out
there mad at medusa or something it's
just stupid well nobody is because that
doesn't have any relevance to i mean i
only hate religions to the extent that
they're
interfering in something that might
affect my life
in a negative way so that's why i don't
really care about you know there's no
zeus worshipers anymore
so well not that i don't let anybody
i don't i don't let anybody interfere
with my life anyway
they pass laws i break those laws i
don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they don't pass any religious laws
anymore anyway
not for lack of trying no
uh sidequest hero said i think it was
twofold this is scientologist they
wanted the skill set
and they wanted to try to catch people
who might have potential to become
famous someday yeah i mean the thing
about scientologists is that they're all
about the benjamins man they're just
they want
more famous people that they can suck in
so they can take all day take their
money that's pretty much all they want
it for them they don't give up they have
a [ __ ] ton of money
uh i've heard they had problems that
they're getting too much money see
they're afraid of losing that tax exempt
status
and they can't sit on it they have to
spend a certain amount of it so they're
constantly building
building and building they'll build a
building that they don't need and it's
just an empty building furnished ready
to go but it's for nothing
but then i'll give it an impressive name
they did that to clear water they
basically took over downtown clearwater
and it's basically just buildings with
books in it
evidently there's councils there trying
to get not the cool kind of buildings
with books in it either
they're [ __ ] dianetics buildings full
of lame books
feelings full of the damn okay okay one
of the pictures that i saw and this was
in clear water
it looked like a storefront
high-tech [ __ ]
sign on it you know it's a scientology
[ __ ] front company
it was beautiful and there's a damn
office and there's all these bookshelves
it looks like you're going to be have
you know looks like a bookstore
the problem is is that each shelf
or each each bookshelf has three shelves
in it
you know what i mean they're like
display shelves like to sell books at
right
each shelf only has one book in it and
dead center
and it's all the same book on every
[ __ ] shelf so
when you look in there you see all these
bookshelves and say like you have a
bookshelf of three each bookshelf has
six books on it
three on either side
there's just row after row after row and
it's the same scientology book over a
big hardcover
it's like they're selling one book
in that place
over and over and there's video screens
of some like scientology commercials
going on
24 7. and you know nobody's going in
there and buying that book it's just one
book over and over and over a huge
[ __ ] building
that's just because they had to have
they had to make that building
yep
ridiculous it is you know you picture
what i'm saying right no i've seen it
you've seen it yeah it's [ __ ]
ridiculous i told you i used to work for
scientologists you act like i don't know
what's going on
i used to live in clearwater
were they doing that kind of [ __ ] back
then um
sort of no i don't think it's quite to
the extent that it is now
because that was like early 2000s but
they were still absolutely doing that
it was just a beautiful i didn't spend a
lot of time down there to be honest with
you it's just a beautiful building
and i had beautiful furniture and [ __ ]
was all real expensive and they were
selling one single book and they had
that whole big old building only had
baby i don't know 20 copies
and they were all spread out
you know it's just weird
weird i imagine they went in there with
a ruler to make sure everything was
perfectly centered too
yeah probably they sound anal retentive
like yeah starbucks 78 says uh zoey lund
sounded like a radical christian she
seemed like
um
she had some problems toward the end
um
and i loved her in ms45 you know she's
she was [ __ ] great in that but
she's she seemed like she was not a real
happy individual and she had like kind
of a lot of mental problems and [ __ ]
like that i think she died kind of young
although i can't remember
what age she was but i'm pretty sure she
died fairly young
um
yeah so what else what else are we going
to talk about anything um
you want to shut it down no no no i was
just like
like well let's get out of here no i was
just uh
my stomach's still kind of
full i gotta i want i want some food i
want some pie but yeah i i don't i'm not
hungry enough yet
and we might have to watch some crustal
christmas yeah crustal christmas
you know what i'm saying i thought i saw
it that was like a [ __ ]
question up here but i forgot
what it was
yes i was reading something about alice
cooper the other day too
that um
he seems like a nice dude actually
they have all kind of stuff emily's he's
always going like feeding the homeless
and all that kind of doing all kind of
charity stuff because i think we were we
talking about that the other day because
we were talking about steven seagal
i you know what i didn't read the
article i just saw the um
[Music]
i just saw the the headline just in my
news feed or whatever
but i g i think kelly lebrock who was
married to steven seagal for a time
came out and like said some kind of
disparaging [ __ ] about him i don't know
if it was necessarily disparaging uh she
was just saying
i don't know i can't remember how she
put it it kind of sounded like she was
saying yeah he's a piece of [ __ ] but she
put it in a more like diplomatic way but
i can't remember the wording that she
used
but it's like i don't know if she just
had a book out or something like that
but she did say something about him so i
have to like find that article that was
a day or two ago because i was thinking
about sending it to you because i was
like oh look something juicy came about
steven seagal but i forgot to send it
that's why
uh lars says sooner or later they must
run out of money the scientologists
no well the wait the individual
scientologists that are paying for
classes i imagine yeah they'll run out
of money because
going up the bridge costs what like
three hundred thousand dollars or
something about going up the bridge
anymore
yeah i don't think they care about the
bridge anymore
the bridge is like their scientology
levels
they're making enough they're almost
effectively uh existing as as a real
estate
scam
yeah at this stage yeah at this stage
they own so much real estate they're
having a problem
controlling how much money they have
because i think the real estate that
they own goes up in value it appreciates
and they and they get richer but they
can't have that kind of value they have
to
they can't appear to be a business they
have to appear to be a church or a
charity
so that it's a huge problem
it's a huge problem with them having too
much money
that's the thing they can't have i wish
i had that problem yeah
hey somebody give me enough money so i
have that problem as well yeah so i can
cry about how i have too much
kind of ocelot asking about dinosaur
embryos i'm not sure what you're talking
about man
yeah i thought i heard something about
that but again i just i kind of just
like skimmed through when i was doing
something else and i was like oh i
should go back and read that and then
where's the dinosaur embryo
i don't know i don't know
i don't know like i said he can he can
write it i'm asking him
uh ilsa says on my watch list christmas
chronicles yeah i think we're gonna
watch that tonight actually yeah you
haven't seen that elsa
well maybe but it's kind of you know
muppet christmas carol we watched that
last night
uh peewee's christmas special
and finished listening to a christmas
carol from 1939 with orson welles
ooh that sounds cool
tammy says any new year's eve plans
probably not um we don't usually go out
on new year's eve because
uh it's amateur hour yeah
and the traffic is atrocious that ass
domain is asking where they can where
you can buy the the cookbook
it is either on amazon or
lulu.com yeah and what's the title again
cooking time cooking with 13.
that's right
um no uh alice cooper was not goth
no he was rock
yeah i mean there there's been like
horror and rock
you know
before goth was a thing yeah you know
you had like screaming jay hawkins and
stuff like that and that's not really
goth music it was just kind of horror
infused or imagery
yeah so but the music isn't really the
same no
there were there was things that
kind of came
close in the psychedelic
era
like
some jim morrison stuff kind of had a
goth
feel to it
but it was psychedelic infused goth
same with uh
the lou reed and the velvet underground
type stuff kinda yeah had some folkish
goth type sounds especially
with uh
oh what's her name
that
nico nico
nico kind of had a goth sound to her and
a lot of
female goth senior singers later on kind
of got had that nico type of sound
uh some of them did the
early night early 80s
um
try to think some
some rolling stones kind of had a goth
kind of a flare to it
not all of it but some of it did like uh
it's painted black kind of had a goth
[ __ ] sound to it
um
some
the first uh some of the early citrus of
mercy
music you know from first last and
always and then before that
you know some of their singles
kind of had
kind of had a
rolling stone sound to it
so there was some crossover on in both
directions well scissors and mercy
cupboards uh they covered a lot of
rolling stones yeah because they i mean
so so there is like a little bit of a
cross over there yeah i don't think
anybody would call the rolling stones of
goth band not by any search of the
imagination
but they did yeah some of their songs
had like some kind of sound that sort of
sounded like that to it yeah um
you know it's kind of you know nothing
comes from
nowhere you know everything is just kind
of like an amalgamation of a bunch of a
little uh you know all kind of different
influences
some of jimi hendrix kind of had a goth
industrial sound to it
that uh some of his especially his early
stuff like the song are you experienced
like half the damn shit's running
backwards in there it's almost kind of
like a the drums are going backwards
uh some of the guitar tracks are being
played backwards
and that man i sound a lot like skinny
puppy
um
the jimi hendrix experience their first
couple album well all of this [ __ ] was
good but that first album was [ __ ]
way ahead of its time people didn't know
what to make of that
it was
almost like proto-industrial
yeah i mean that was uh pretty different
yeah at the time third stone from the
sun
that that song was almost like an
industry almost like a skinny puppy song
ej maniac knows what i'm talking about
yeah sergeant deadhead's bringing up the
stooges yes yeah uh and dj manic said
yeah the sister of mercy covered iggy
pop too yes they did yeah uh yeah
bauhaus covered a lot of that stupid uh
bauhaus covered
uh you know bowie obviously brian eno
um they did an iggy pop song did they
didn't they iggy pop had a lot of good
stuff yeah he had some bad stuff too but
no peter murphy covered fun time which i
think was iggy pop or the stooges that
was not until 88 though
but
i'm kind of thinking oh bauhaus covered
john kale
rose garden funeral of swords that was a
john kayle song
but
yeah they could they liked a lot of that
kind of stuff there's a i mean i i kind
of feel like there's a bigger crossover
with
glam
yeah more than anything like it's in in
the look i guess i always kind of
figured what particularly like bauhaus
they to me they always seemed like a
dark glam band although bauhaus are
maybe not the
not the purest example because
they had a lot of other influences too
like reggae
and stuff there's another one another
goth glam band that i'm revisiting from
the 80s grantham's might remember it's
called jean loves jezebel
their early albums their first two or
three were really good and it was these
two twins they were in the band
uh
they both sang and one of them played
guitar and then they had a band behind
them
they were from wales yeah they were way
out the welsh
and they were really good
um it's funny though they they
constantly the two twins are always
fighting
they're fighting over who should be in
the band or not and eventually the band
broke up into two each one with one twin
and they they sounded just alike
evidently you can't have bands with
brothers man just never gene loves
jezebel uh jesus and mary chain
uh was it was it wasn't it oasis was it
oasis that had the brothers that fought
all the time the gallaghers it's just
kind of out of for whatever reason you
just can't put like two brothers in a
band they just it's
the ego is too much they got all their
stuff
on youtube
the two albums i recommend recommend are
the immigrant which i think is their
first one it's the first one that i saw
jean loves jezebel immigrant it's real
good and then
after that one another one came out
called i think it was called discover
that was really good yeah i had both of
those and then there was a um a uh
there's a video on there uh gene love
jezebel live at the roxy it's a live
show it's really good and it's it's off
of the album
they did that for the tour on the
discover album and it has songs from
both
immigrant and and discovered and it was
it was a really good band it was kind of
like
it's kind of like glam uh the two twins
basically wore [ __ ]
they were kind of like in drag almost
cross between
goth and
old ladies they almost kind of dressed
like old ladies big [ __ ]
weird just weird [ __ ] and then like uh
motley crew
with some of the visuals were mixed in
there almost like a like a goth monthly
crew dressed like in color real colorful
silk [ __ ] clothes and [ __ ]
and but then it was just kind of like
medieval it's just
they just had their own thing going the
sound was kind of like
cross between the chameleons and
the cure maybe
i guess they got a little poppy for me
later later yeah i didn't like them out
later later they tried to go mainstream
i liked him when they were
kind of unknown up and coming
goth band really but they were they were
they were showing up on golf compilation
albums yeah and to me it was a goth band
they were just trying to go mainstream
well it's kind of they they kind of did
what the cult was doing yeah like they
come for the cult started out as
southern death cult and everything yeah
and they were like a death rock band and
then they went more toward like glam
metal yeah the co-host kind of reminded
me of ac dc in a much slicker version of
ac dc without [ __ ] guitar solos dj
maniac says there was a band in the 60s
that was experimenting with sampling and
tape loops way before any established
industrial acts i'll send you guys a
link they're called cro-magnon yeah i
had actually heard of them i don't think
of any heard any of their stuff but i
remember them being mentioned before as
being like way super ahead of their time
so like i said it's just kind of like
i feel like a lot of this stuff is only
known in hindsight when somebody that
was doing that same kind of thing later
got kind of popular
and then everybody
busts out and said you know it's just
kind of like that i know this is like a
weird example but this is just kind of
like how everybody got all head up about
found footage movies when the blair
witch project came out but people didn't
realize that cannibal holocaust
was a found footage movie that was made
back in the late 70s in italy and but
the fact that everybody thought that
blair witch project was like the first
found footage movie i don't know if
people thought it was the first one but
i guess it was like the most successful
to that point but it wasn't the first
time that that had been done though
yeah i guess gene love jezebel did kind
of look like new york dolls a little bit
yeah a bit
very glammy
it could look like a glam band but it
sounded like a goth band for the day of
the times you guys could check it
it's online you know gene loved jezebel
it was good
grandparents hammer said i heard a
christmas song today by the waitresses
oh yeah called christmas wrapping yeah
they play that one at uh at eye bar
pretty much every year if you go there
around christmas time
kind of goth kind of new wave yeah the
waitresses had a couple
of songs back in the early 80s i
wouldn't call them a one-hit wonder i
think they had two or three hits but
yeah if you get any kind if you go to
any like new wave kind of club or get
any kind of new wave christmas
compilation that song's gonna be on
there it's like pretty well known
um
yeah these old guys play gigs forever
i don't know yeah
um dj maniac says ilsa and i watched a
bunch of old sisters videos at the club
last time we were out and boy were they
cheesy as [ __ ]
yeah the old sister's house
what the videos yeah the videos are
terrible what's well the one for black
planet is basically them just like
driving around in a convertible that's
the car from the monkeys yeah that's the
g yeah that's the car from the monkeys
well andrew eldridge i kind of feel like
he's trolling people to some degree yeah
i don't think i just think they didn't
have the budget for anything well that
too yeah
i mean yeah yeah nothing had been
codified yet into anything and
he decided
okay so reconnect then
okay yeah i lost the connection there
for a second it started going right back
okay yeah it says it's back okay
we'll see if it is
i like the sisters of mercy but whenever
i saw andrew eldritch
interviewed like 120 minutes or whatever
he always came across as like such a
condescending
douche hat you know what i'm saying he
always just really came across like i'm
smarter than all of you well it was easy
to do that back then yeah
television was a one-way like he just
always came across like that i was like
wow what a chode but you know
his music's good
but he just always came across as kind
of like a snot like one he's very edge
lordy in the sense of
i'm smarter than him i'm too cool for
this i'm too he just always came across
like that well the whole rock star thing
back in those days was to be aloof and
inaccessible and looking you're like on
another planet uh and uh
they didn't survive that
they didn't really survive those guys
didn't survive when the industry changed
you know what i mean yeah the industry
changed with the money kind of got
sucked out of that
you know because the record industry
[ __ ] fell apart and there goes their
[ __ ] you know
there goes their [ __ ] high horse you
know it vanished
all of a sudden you had to be nice to
your fans
i know imagine having to be nice to
people
that's so shitty
[Laughter]
which that's great that's why uh i
wanted to be i wanted to be famous just
specifically so i could be addicted to
people god damn it
if you look at uh
um like in rob halford
every live show i've seen recorded on
youtube and as recent you know in the
past 10 years when they're up there he
stops the show and says we are only two
we are only touring and making albums
because we have the best fans in the
world every time we
have a show it sells out you guys are
always showing up and and they [ __ ] a
huge you know thunderous applause and
you know [ __ ]
rob knows what side of the bread his
bread is buttered you know what i mean
if you don't have fans coming to your
shows you don't have a career you know
true and um
his fans show up
and i you know i really like the fact
that he recognizes that if if he were to
get up there and do [ __ ] be a dick
like you know like
like [ __ ] peter murphy and throw
[ __ ] liquor bottles at your [ __ ]
audience and tell them that they're
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and freak out and
get thrown out of [ __ ] your own
events then you know there goes your
business poor peter how the mighty have
fallen yeah drugs drugs are a hell of a
drug
specifically meth yeah meth is a hell of
a drug
yeah
[ __ ] attacking your audience and [ __ ]
because he's just so bad i'm paranoid he
thinks everybody's making fun of him
well don't act like an ass and nobody
yeah just a pro tip
it's a vicious cycle really um you know
grantor's hammer says question do you
think btk celebrates christmas and a
solomon sincere way or just visualizes
killing more families
i want isn't that [ __ ] up i wonder if
like some serial killers that are
incarcerated
um
if they have some kind of little
christmas fantasy where they're like
well i'm gonna have my regular christmas
fantasy about killing people and you
know burying them in a hole but they'll
be covered with christmas lights or have
like a little santa hat on i wonder if
they have like seasonal appropriate
killing fantasies i think uh btk
is uh
totally compartmentalized
he doesn't think that he killed those
women he had a certain part of him
killed those women
but the real him is a good guy he got
set up by the other one he couldn't
control it's that type of deal so what
he does for christmas this is how this
is how i imagine it
he's locked up right in the pen
he sits around going well you know
reason why these guys are here is
because they come from broken homes
it's terrible terrible nobody takes care
of money give them some christmas cheer
maybe i should do something for all
these guys
save their souls and stuff you know what
i mean be good to them for christmas and
he's probably the type of dude i got a
christmas tree guys he's trying to build
a christmas tree
[Laughter]
and he's putting
presents underneath there you know what
i mean look at he's got all these dudes
he knows their prison names you know hey
too sweet too sweet i gotta put it
give that to your old man share that
[ __ ] with your old man you know he has
some cigarettes for you yeah you know
the guys going by the [ __ ] cell and
[ __ ] [ __ ] butt clap yeah butt clap
[Laughter]
well he he gives out he gives out all
the [ __ ] presents to to the host
yeah where's suki suki
give this to your sister
yeah hands it out to the prison hose
first
yeah i could definitely see well one i
could definitely see him being like
super uptight about we have to do
christmas correctly yeah yeah oh yeah um
you know it has to be exactly like a
traditional
[ __ ] sing christmas carols right and
he goes nah you mispronounced that yeah
that's not how that that's not how those
lyrics it's not how you mean that's not
how you do the lyrics we have to start
over yeah yeah but yeah yeah i could
totally see him being that type of dude
making him [ __ ] do carol
make him do carols from one cell to the
next
yeah oh my god yeah
starbucks 78 says you two should write a
serial killer sitcom yeah
well i i always pitch it always i pitch
or [ __ ] beat the btk uh being seeing
himself as the responsible one
he's there to civilize all these people
yeah i mean he's way above all this you
know he's gonna help out now he's gonna
help society while some of these guys
are gonna get released so
i need to help society by improving
these men you know it's gonna be like
that you know i need i need to be an
example for to them you know of how to
turn your life around it's gonna be [ __ ]
like that you know what i mean yeah yeah
i know he said yeah i did good work for
the church now i'm going to do continue
to do good do good work for the church
yeah i could totally see it yeah yeah
he's more like [ __ ] like that yeah
he believes it though
yeah he believes it
yeah i totally think he does but also
he's batshit crazy yeah of course
that's why he's locked up that's why he
killed his wife he's [ __ ] crazy
i told you in that [ __ ] book you
should read that book actually
um
just
listening to his thought processes was
just so bizarre yeah
i was just kind of like well i guess
this means i'm not a serial killer
that's good to know cause
this dude sounds like a [ __ ] loon
wow you always gotta do something good
you know
but no he's back there trying to redeem
himself
a little late for that dennis guarantee
you
should have started yourself in his own
eyes
sure yeah
i don't know man i just i'm gonna make a
difference he's gonna make it up you're
making a difference i guess yeah
yeah mary connell said he was not caught
in 31 years yeah it's true dna and
floppy disk got him caught and honestly
i'm kind of of the opinion that
maybe if he hadn't decided that he was
gonna start taunting the police again
after that many years they might not
have caught him again
you know what i mean because it had been
so long
so
i don't know if it i mean it was a cold
case at that point so i don't know if
anybody was like actively looking for
him now they might have caught him
eventually because of like the dna stuff
like they caught the golden state killer
so they might have gotten around to him
then
but i think it definitely uh sped up the
process him trying to get himself back
into the limelight again
so i he's only got himself to blame for
that i think he wanted to get caught
maybe yeah maybe he was just like sick
of
sick of like looking over his shoulder
all the time being afraid i'm not really
sure
i'm not really sure
i think he was afraid that i think he
was afraid that he was going to die and
not be not be recognized for his great
achievements
and him that that was his yeah it might
have been that because he definitely did
see his motivations definitely seemed
more
toward his own self-aggrandizement
rather than
you're of being afraid of getting caught
yeah you're looking at this as some kind
of like shame or something he's very
proud of himself now some serial killers
are shame-based and they do they are
worried about getting caught and [ __ ]
like that but yeah he he was one of
those ones that was kind of like
yeah he definitely thought a lot of
himself yeah
and
he wanted recognition like he wanted to
be famous yeah well when he was speaking
to the judge he was speaking to the
judge as if he and the judge were on the
same level that they're equals
well you know we're all professionals
here well let's just get this out in the
open and this is you know in my little
projects and this is what i did but and
you know and she was a little upset
[Laughter]
you know we're all in law enforcement so
we know what we're talking about because
wait a minute you're a dog catcher well
i was gonna be a cop you know but you
know that's the kind of that's the
thinking you know yeah and he's i'm
gonna just help out and help you guys
catch the bad guy okay and uh yeah a
little time for me to go then you know
it's just he's like that you know
that's exactly what he's doing he's
manning up and he's telling everybody
what he did and [ __ ] that so you can
be amazed at his [ __ ]
brilliance you know his criminal
brilliance and [ __ ] how you know
well you know yeah he he legit thought
he was something
mastermind or something only reason why
i was caught you know is because the
cops have no honor i asked him if they
could catch me if i sent him a floppy
and they they lied they said no we could
never catch you like that stop be honest
of course they're gonna lie so hey they
cheated that's probably how he thinks
about it yeah it's [ __ ] right
they only caught me because they cheated
yeah
i'm like i'm like have you ever
considered though how stupid that is to
even ask that question of the cops of
course they're going to lie to you you
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
they broke their word
yeah i'm a man of my word and honor i
would never lie you know that's what
that's what the thinking is yeah they
lied
yeah he had like a really weird yeah he
has a really weird like code of honor
i mean if you if you think about it it
sort of makes sense if you're a crazy
person yeah but crazy yeah
but he definitely did have that kind of
and honestly like i think that was one
of the things that like pissed me off
the most when i was reading that book
because one of the things
that and not just with serial killers
but anybody that
clearly
thinks they're super super smart but
they're really really not and sometimes
what you have this too and this is the
thing the dun and krueger effect and
sometimes people that are sort of like
dumb as [ __ ]
think they're smarter than everybody
else even though they're a lot stupider
yeah i was i saw a guy who like did a
study on
on this
there's a bunch of different levels that
this happens on okay
some people and i think he even had
cutoffs of it if a person is under 85
percent
oh if their iq is lower than 85
they fall into the [ __ ]
or 80 or 85 i don't remember he said it
was
they fall into the trap of
underestimating the intelligence of
everyone else
they think that they're smart as [ __ ]
that everybody else is dumb
because they don't doesn't make sense to
them so everybody seems like an idiot
but
the reason why it doesn't make sense is
because they don't have the brain power
to compute it
what's happening well and also i think
they also don't have the brain power to
put themselves in somebody else's shoes
or to be able to see things from another
person's perspective yeah so they they
get into a lot of trouble because they
think they're going to get away with
things that nobody could get away with
because everyone's like yeah they're a
lot smarter
but then that same guy said that there's
you also get into
trouble with uh midwidths which are
people that are like 110 to like 130 iq
they're smart smarter than average but
they think they're a lot smarter than
they really are yeah that's kind of more
what i'm talking about with btk because
he didn't seem like a dummy no he was
about 110 120 iq he did do some stuff
that was kind of like smart but
it wasn't as smart as he thought he was
now what's funny is that the midwifes
end up a lot in um
uh like college type
colleges and college type professions
so you know a lot a lot of midwifes will
end up as some kind of technician or a
doctor or even a lawyer
and they think they're [ __ ] smart
really smart but they know their job but
they're not that smart and they think
everybody else is dumber than them
but then that same guy also noticed that
he was talking about the differences in
society between england and america
and he he noticed that
the intelligence
of
guys that are really [ __ ] gifted and
real
rich in other words people like in the
millionaire billionaire
class um
guys that infant come up with some new
angles and [ __ ] make a bunch of money
their personalities are a lot like
people in in in the lower classes
uh their communication skills their real
gruff
they're real kind of what you would call
based
uh they don't believe the main they
don't believe in mainstream
middle class morality uh they're they're
kind of sophisticated in certain ways
and they're above that and they also
don't care about impressing anybody
because they have so much money and
power they don't have to
so he was just saying there's a
there's a lot of crossover between the
criminal class and the [ __ ] ruling
classes as well as their their
personalities are a lot alike
rich people and gangsters hang out a lot
uh you know if at least back in the day
depending on how socially acceptable it
was
it's just an interesting uh
intellect is not what
a lot of people think it is there's a
lot of different kinds of intellect
but at the top it's predators
you know
or you wouldn't be there one thing that
i found was very interesting that you
just reminded me of um i have this great
book called watching the english
and it was written by a british woman
and she essentially wrote it
as if it was a sociological study of her
own people
so she was trying to like say like these
different cultural things like about
english people because she was trying to
like you know step back at one reserve
and see what maybe other people
uh were perceiving about english people
and she said one thing that was very
because she was went a lot into
uh classes because i kind of feel like
class differences are more pronounced uh
in the uk maybe not so much nowadays
they're saying the same thing but um
one thing that she noted
was that it was interesting and i'd have
to reread it uh because it was actually
really fascinating because i lived in
the uk for a little while so i did like
see some of this stuff
is that
you could kind of tell like what
uh socioeconomic level this person was
at because like [ __ ] that was in their
house and things like that and she said
interestingly if you see people that
really that are wearing like a certain
brand or have certain things in their
house or something like that that's
almost always
middle class yeah or upper middle class
they're like people that are actually
upper class as in landed gentry
they said because they have so much
money especially if they're old money
um they tend to
not really care how they dress they
drive old beater cars
um because they don't have to like you
said impress anyone they don't care and
money they've had money their whole
lives so it doesn't really mean anything
to them yeah she was talking more about
old money
right so it's just kind of like they can
and they've always just been able to
just do whatever they wanted to
and they kind of live in a bubble in a
way yeah so they're not so so they're
like really the only people who are
trying to impress anybody are people who
are kind of more like upwardly mobile
yeah and they're trying to like impress
other people with like oh look i can
afford you know this that and the other
thing whereas somebody that actually had
a [ __ ] ton of money would not care
didn't give a [ __ ] about any of that no
and well he was all this guy was uh he's
also british and he was studying both
sides he said something was similar what
you're talking about
he said that the the words and the
phrases that they use there's some cross
over if uh somebody from the upper
middle class or the middle class if if
you say something they don't understand
what you said they would say excuse me
or pardon me or i'm sorry what did you
say that kind of thing it would be very
kind of nice
if um
if a lower class person or another
person from the underclass couldn't
understand what you were saying they
would say what
what
you know what yeah
well you go to the billionaire class and
if you if they don't understand what
you're saying they're like what what
they so they're using the same words
as somebody from another class the same
kind of phrase what what
they don't do they don't use niceties
like that
like pardon me and excuse me just what
although i guess in a lot of ways though
i mean i'm trying to think about
i guess for me that'd be like context
dependent
if i was around people i didn't know
yeah uh you know and they said something
i'd probably say something a little more
polite sounding but if i'm around you or
friends or something maybe like what the
[ __ ] you say yeah it's like well
his explanation was is that
people from the upper
middle class and upper middle class
their priorities is status and they want
to appear to be
as educated and polite as they possibly
can okay
but the people from uh from the from the
billionaire class or the ruling class
and the people in the underclass don't
give a [ __ ] it's just what it's very
um what was the word that he used
practical
no flowery language just real practical
language
because they're they're just trying to
be clear
they're not trying to impress people
mary says that the irs they say the
poorest and the richest feel like they
don't owe poor cheats and wealthy cheats
have the same thought process yeah look
out for yourself yeah yeah grampur's
hammer says tell tom i got a book for
christmas called the dark secrets of
shtf survival okay about how he survived
the balkan war i'll mail it when i'm
done oh cool for discussion on the new
channel okay yeah you need to get that
started okay
mary also says read the millionaire next
door i've actually been wanting to read
that uh i'll get around to it one of
these days
uh yeah tammy said yeah i had a lady
tell me one time the people wearing all
the labels are trying to look rich where
the rich are trying to look poor oh
definitely
i mean if you've seen like a lot of the
um
you know if you watch like some big
fancy [ __ ] fashion show with all this
kind of stuff i do kind of feel like a
lot of those fashions kind of come from
street fashions
is where it starts from and then like
they make like a fancier version of it
yeah those fashion shows are ridiculous
that none of that stuff's in reality
well the thing about those though is
that i think it's like selling art yeah
that's what i mean no one's really meant
to wear those like his everyday kind of
stuff it's more like an artistic
statement just like any other just like
a painting or sculpture or anything like
that and then what happens is that you
know they'll do the shows and if people
respond well to it then they'll do like
a toned-down version of it that they'll
sell in stores for example that's like
another thing that they do so no one's
really meant to wear that crazy [ __ ] if
you read between the lines a lot of that
a lot of that uh art
selling and art dealing not not talking
about
rembrandts and [ __ ] classical art but
just the [ __ ] where a guy puts a piece
of underwear on a damn paint thing and
rolls up some paint on it sells it for
10 million dollars that's money
laundering that's what that is
they're not [ __ ] selling art
sheila answers
jenny you would see it in palm beach all
those mitzner mansions were filled with
worn rugs and old furniture nothing
updated old kitchens and bathrooms after
the old owners died
yeah i kind of feel like i mean
i don't know i suppose there's like a
fine line i guess but people that
actually have money particularly people
that
come from money like their families have
had money for several generations
because money has never meant anything
to them they've never needed money um
you know they they travel in other
circles with other wealthy people and
they don't really have to interact with
the hoi polloi to any great degree
talking about monies is so cool
yes yeah because they don't that it's
something they've never
occurred to them which is crazy i can't
imagine what that must be like but well
i knew people like that brazil i went to
school with them yeah i mean they owned
brazil their parents owned brazil
and to them it's just tacky talking
about that [ __ ] of course they're rich
why are you [ __ ] they've been rich
for generations why didn't [ __ ] you
bringing it up that's the way that's the
way they think
and no and they didn't [ __ ] dress in
real fancy clothes they just they didn't
want to call any attention to themselves
they didn't nobody didn't want anybody
who they were
because they just walk outside
and go to little barzino and [ __ ]
drink [ __ ] cachaca with [ __ ] poor
people and hey they didn't like hanging
out with rich people
most of the time they're not doing
anything anyway
you know and they were teenagers they
were just partying the ones i knew
oop
yep went right a little bit
it looks like it's not it's coming back
it's not going down to zero okay
it's not going down i don't know what
you guys missed nothing probably yeah
nothing mary said a guy who worked uh at
a bank said the people driving and
wearing all the fancy stuff are in debt
yeah because like i said they're trying
to impress other people yeah that's what
i was saying before i got cut off i was
just saying rich kids that i grew up
with in brazil
they didn't want to look rich at all
they just wanted to not be noticed and
they'd go around and [ __ ] just party
with [ __ ] regular people
you know they were teenagers when i knew
them knew them that but
they were kind of ashamed of [ __ ]
vast wealth
it was like not cool
elsa said my best friend's boyfriend's
family is rich and they're pissed at him
for applying to law school they think
it's a shitty career that's below him
yeah well it is they want him to just
work in the family business yeah it is
although the thing about it though is
that i mean
you should just do what you want to do
if you want if you want to be a lawyer
be a lawyer yeah it's i don't know why
you want to be a lawyer well you're not
that guy so i mean if that guy wants to
be a lawyer
he clearly doesn't have to because his
family has money so you got to [ __ ]
straighten something out okay
universities and university
educations
are kind of a latent a product of late
middle medieval era
that was when
the monarchs and landed gentry needed a
competent servant class to help them get
[ __ ] done
they're they're servants to the rich
they're not the rich people all right
rich people don't
some of those [ __ ] rich people they
have degrees but they bought them
you know
you they go maybe they would go to
university but just a party
i don't think they
other people probably did their tests
and [ __ ] but when your dad gives
harvard university five six million
dollars you're going to come out of
there with a degree
you just are
so they don't take initiative seriously
but
then when they get out they don't work
in any business that anybody else owns
they just make sure that everybody
working for them gets everything done
money just
fast money in their accounts they can't
lose money
you know tammy says that's why i'm
walking around my house in a ball gown
because i'm poor
[Laughter]
so going to universities and getting a
big degree is really just from the point
of view of the ruling class that's
another sign of being poor that's just a
servant class
ilsa says he needs financial
independence from them because they're
really toxic yeah i see i can see
i mean being raised in a wealthy family
yeah you do get like a [ __ ] ton of
advantages but
if they're shitty ass people
then yeah you're gonna have to get the
[ __ ] out of there at some point
and if you don't want anything else to
do with them then you're gonna have to
make your own way i think right now all
the richest guys the richest the richest
guys at least in the west didn't didn't
graduate from universities i don't think
elon musk did didn't i don't think uh
um bill gates has a degree does he or
one maybe he bought one
but i think they kind of came from
nothing those are internet guys they
were billionaires by the time they were
in their 20s if i remember correctly
weren't they and the guy who [ __ ]
runs amazon
i think he's yeah no i'm three
the all the rich guys are just i don't
think i don't think any of them win well
i'm not going to say that across
unequivocally because i don't know i'm
pretty sure they didn't go
they might have degrees but they bought
them
yeah elsa said uh he's got to get away
from his family that's the main reason
why it sounds like a good idea right now
yeah so
i totally don't blame him for that
because you know
can't pick your family that's for sure
gates dropped out of hard harvard said
sheila yeah i don't blame him i know
that scene [ __ ] harvard
grampur's hammer said i worked a
retirement gig this fall transporting
pontoon boats for storage
the people who tipped weren't the rich
folks with a hundred thousand dollar
boats it was the regular folks with
modest boats who tipped i've actually
heard that from a lot of people i know
that worked in the service industry they
said usually the richest people are the
[ __ ] tight wads when it comes to
tipping they won't tip nothing
you know what i mean
which makes sense because they don't
[ __ ] have any uh
they don't have any empathy for you
they've never been like you
yeah they never actually had to like
work for a living yeah the ones that
have been the ones that are a little bit
[ __ ] broke or know what work is they
appreciate you you appreciate your
service the other ones just [ __ ] take
your service for granted well yeah
they're just like what these people
aren't just like slaves that were there
just will do everything for me for free
yeah and just appear like little fairies
that don't have rent or have to buy food
or anything yeah you know it's it's
infuriating
but you know i'm not excusing it it's
just a lot of them just live in bubbles
and they're so used to having everything
done for them
and not really having to think about it
that you know
um
yeah mary said poor people do more
charity percentage-wise yeah that is
absolutely true
as as a percentage of i mean obviously
the amount rich people give is more
because they can afford to give more but
as a percentage of their income then
yeah poor and middle-class people do get
more
at least last i heard um let's see
janet says my daughter is an attorney uh
my mom and stepdad hang with warren
buffett they know how to keep their
money
yeah
not giving it to anybody that's how they
keep it i guess i don't know i can't
imagine
what it would be like
because i've never had money my whole
life so it's like i don't really
that must be really strange
to not worry about money ever i can't
imagine what that must be like
i'm sure it comes with its own
you know i'm sure it comes with its own
uh
other set of problems
but
i don't know it's i just feel like
whatever problems it comes with it's got
to be better than just like worrying
about oh [ __ ] i'm not going to pay my
rent next month
you know
i don't know i don't worry about it
well of course you don't worry about it
no you don't have to worry about it no
if it doesn't happen it doesn't happen
they can't kill me
they who
the people that i owe money to they
can't kill me if i do owe money i don't
owe anybody money
but you know
if i can't pay a bill i can't pay it
says don't worry about it
yeah janet says my stepdad encouraged
all the grandkids to be attorneys or
bankers
or to do banking
yeah
my
when i was younger and i was trying to
figure out what i wanted to do like go
to college and stuff my grandfather said
he'd pay for me to go to college but
when i told him i wanted to do graphic
design he didn't want to pay for it then
yeah he wanted me to do accounting for
some reason
which
i guess although most accountants don't
make a [ __ ] ton of money either no to be
honest with you and lawyers don't make
any money
depends on what kind of lawyer you are
but yeah and well that's the thing too
about like you know accountants there's
a lot of those yeah um you know i'm not
saying graphic designers make a lot of
money they don't but
i think it's a i think it's kind of like
a misconception
that certain that oh if you get a degree
in a certain
for a certain uh you know
job then that's going to guarantee i
mean that doesn't
it's only kind of like the top tier
of pretty much any kind of job that you
make a decent living at most people just
make kind of like an average middling
you know even stuff that people think of
as like rich people professions
or you know people that are comfortable
i don't know if they make as much money
as people think they do although some
people make more money than you would
think
doctors and lawyers don't have good
don't don't make enough money for the
amount of hassle they got to put up with
i just do i just wouldn't do it
i'd rather be a damn plumber or an ac a
[ __ ] ac engineer putting in air
conditioners
[ __ ] a lot of money in that those
dudes are [ __ ] pushing when you
actually [ __ ] go
through their expenses and you look at
what they're what their bottom lines and
what they actually take home
they're doing as well as a doctor with a
lot less hassle a lot more free time
probably
but they make a lot of their money yeah
i mean doctors do make a lot of money
depending on what your specialty is
um
doctors do make a lot of money in the
u.s but i don't know if it would be
worth it one for the amount of schooling
that you have to do two for the amount
of licensing you have to do yeah there's
three um your hours well it's i don't
think it's so much that because they
still do
pretty well like financially but you're
pretty much always on call you always
have people you know and i don't think i
could deal with i mean somebody like me
it's like i don't think i could deal
with like what if i [ __ ] up or like
what if somebody died like on my watch
and it was my mistake and it's like you
know what i mean it's like i don't think
i would really want the
i don't really think i would want the
emotional baggage that goes with it and
i also wouldn't like like you said just
being on call 24 7. like if you because
you if you have a patient
that they they have some kind of [ __ ]
up thing happen in the middle of the
night they can they're gonna wake your
ass up and you gotta go down there so
it's not like you know so i that's why i
couldn't really be a nurse or something
like that i mean if people want to be
doctors and nurses and stuff [ __ ] man
more power to you but
i don't i wouldn't want to do it it just
seems like it seems like man it would
just be so draining just physically and
emotionally i think big tom's got the
right idea a friend of ours named big
tom big old black dude friend of mine
he [ __ ] owns mannequins
he he started
he sold he had a tire repair shop he
wanted out of that so bad we
he finally sold that [ __ ] off and
[ __ ] opened this bar he wanted me to
come work from this bar and i was like
dude i'm your friend we can't i can't
work for you man friends aren't supposed
to be working for each other but he got
mannequins going and he's making money
hand over fist and he's buying another
bar
just up the street from there he's going
to take over [ __ ] samford
um and he's got some other guys
uh as partners yeah our friend scotty
scott he's in there opening it up
that one's going to be more like a
high-end cocktail bar or a cocktail type
it's going to be it's going to be the
theme of it is like old like 20s
like roaring 20s
great gatsby type of look if you have
the proper
location if you have the right friends
and but in in the
in the entertainment industry when it
comes to djs who have followings and you
have graphic designers like jenny like
and you have online people that can help
you promote through the [ __ ] a scene
that will come around
a bar [ __ ] nightclub will make money
hands over fist if it's in the right
location and you didn't pay too much for
the licensing
and
he didn't pay hardly anything for his
licensing
that's still on my first drink okay it's
back it's back
hey look it looks like it's back yeah it
is okay
we don't know what the [ __ ] deal is
like i said maybe more people are online
tonight than i thought yeah
uh
yeah ilsa says uh i'm just not
interested in working technology coding
et cetera being a nurse is pretty good
you can make six figures even without
the pandemic and work three days a week
although it's definitely not easy
um yeah she said it's less financial
investment for a greater return being a
nurse practitioner
probably so although that seems like it
would still be a really really hard job
i kind of feel like nurses
in a lot depending on what the field is
i do kind of feel like they work harder
than doctors and don't get paid as much
i think they still get paid pretty good
but i don't think they get paid as much
as doctors and i think they do
the lion's share of the work to be
honest with you that's just my
perception civilian careers if you ask
me entertainment that's the way to go
yeah but not everybody can do that i'm
just talking about it not everyone's
entertaining
it doesn't have anything to do with
other people has to do with me
i said from my point of view it'd be
entertainment
everybody's
nev everybody does what they can do you
try to find your niche everybody has a
different niche yeah everybody's good at
something it's funny how like
they're trying to do a cookie-cutter
approach with education where everybody
can be anything everybody is everybody
yeah there's not a there's no bigger lie
in the [ __ ] universe
everybody can't do anything you have to
find something you can do
if everybody could do any anything i'd
be a pro basketball player angle
happened everybody cannot do anything
some people are just not cut out for
certain things
well i just kind of feel like people
should just
you know see see what it is that you can
do what do you like to do what are you
good at and then you got to find
yourself make that a job some way to
make that a job yeah you know and i
understand that everybody can't do that
because everybody doesn't have the same
opportunities you don't want your advice
isn't for everybody the isis the advice
is you find what you can do so that is
good advice for everybody everybody will
have a different response depending on
who you are
mary says millionaire next door that
book she was talking about earlier it
shows that business owners like a car
shop or ac installation they are
secretly millionaires yeah that's what
i've heard and it's yeah it's people
like particularly if you live in florida
if you have like uh an ac
company that fixes acs especially if you
can like have a crew that go out there
like the same day yeah yeah
yeah you can probably make money hand
over fists down here because man because
you're gonna [ __ ] die if you don't
have ac down here
in the dead of summer if your [ __ ]
outside unit goes out
people will beg you to come please come
here right now anything
[Laughter]
and everybody's busy all those crews are
busy and like man yeah yeah cause most
of the time you can't get anybody there
for a few days at least they're like
it's gonna be about four or five days
i'll throw another 500 on top if you
come right now
uh
i can be there in 12 hours okay yeah
yeah good good good that's that's and i
totally get it because we've had our aac
go out before and that is not fun yep
if i'd had an extra 500 i totally would
have thrown it but i didn't yeah but if
i did have that to throw at somebody
like just to come out there earlier i
totally they do
they do i know they start big like i
said i would do it too if i had it but i
don't
because there are people that people
that are savvy will go well how much
will it cost to get me to the front of
the waiting line yeah and they'll go you
know drop me 500 i'll be there in 12
hours
on top of the bill okay
and you make a lot of money during that
time
that's cash
cash cash money
yeah because you really i really unless
you're really really shitty at your job
i don't know how you can go poor fixing
ac units nope
can't and really you don't need a lot of
schooling um
the college i went to they did um
they did a one-year
uh certification program and it was
cheap you just did the did the year
certification or nine months or however
long it was mississippi was six months
and uh you know and then you just you
got all the [ __ ] and
yeah i mean obviously to set up your own
business you're gonna need like some
capital and [ __ ] like that
but you could get into
tools yep i mean if you have a truck and
tools or you could get in with a company
until you saved up enough to like go out
on your own you could do that as a hand
that's what i was doing
i mean that seems like the easiest way
before i went to the army i wasn't
working as [ __ ] ac guy going doing up
and making ducks
i mean it's hard work but [ __ ] yeah
it's hot hot miserable but they paid
yeah that was william whitman's company
it was my dad's best friend and that was
his his right hand man helping him
install
and sometimes we just switch out outside
units that was [ __ ] fast and easy
sometimes we'd [ __ ] fix [ __ ]
compressors
it was [ __ ] hot though man dad whoo
setting up umbrellas on [ __ ] tripods
and doing all you can do
drinking ice water and [ __ ] tea
and sometimes you're up in an addict
[ __ ] you're just sweating out [ __ ]
gallons of water it's miserable
but you're making you might be making
one to two hundred dollars cash a day
as a hand
see every time that i'm driving around
in florida
and i see somebody getting a new roof
put on and all the people like working
on the roof in like [ __ ] august yeah
i'm like [ __ ] i hope you guys are
getting paid a really lot of money right
now because i would not want to be up on
that [ __ ] roof
in august
for hours and hours like all that
[ __ ] hot tar and [ __ ] like how do
they live
how do they not die i don't understand
it they're tough i guess i guess they're
used to it i guess some people don't
mind it as much
but like i said i was born here i can't
[ __ ] stand it just
[ __ ] man
i'm in the air conditioning and i get
out of the shower and i'm like oh god
it's hot in here it's so sticky i hate
it i just hate it but you know
but man some people be like up on the
[ __ ] roof all day some blasting down
on you blaster one says
i love how you guys have never asked
people to hit that like button i think
you're the only channel nazis
[ __ ] it man you can't honestly i never
like
i never think about it yeah
we've said it a couple times i think
well you said it a couple times yeah
honestly it's like well for a long time
tom's like oh we should probably like
mention like you know
say you know hit the like button or
leave a comment or uh you know patreon
or something like that but i always just
forget yeah i get to say well i get so
wrapped up in the conversation that
we're having with you know with you and
you guys and stuff it's just like i
forget
i don't know i'm just having a good time
i'm not worried about it
i'm not worried about it
um hugo says i'm a prop builder i work
with wood and metal tools
uh
yeah see
grantham's hammer says oh this is a good
question
what was the best and worst jobs you've
both ever had oh [ __ ] that's easy
what was it so what was that
worst one i had was before i was in the
army
i was living down in detroit
this was uh i guess it was 1987 or 88
worked at a place called spring
engineering
which was a company that made springs
and little parts for
ford they were a subcontractor we sell
the ford motor company
and i had a job where
all day long and it paid okay but it was
only like four days a week i think so
it's just right under full time they
[ __ ] you over on the hours it was not a
a union job
had this big ass [ __ ] box these
little metal things that looked like a
dab shoehorn you know remembers little
shoehorns used to have it
looked like a shoehorn with two with two
slots and one side of it and you put it
on this machine it held it and you took
two rivets and put it in those slot and
then you hit these machines and thing
came down and pressed those two rivets
through those holes and it was a car
door part
and then you take that thing and throw
it in the other box next to you and the
forklifts would bring one huge box after
the other and that's all you did all day
long is pop two rivets into that [ __ ]
thing that drove me [ __ ] crazy i
could see that yeah i would be i would
literally go insane i [ __ ] went
insane [ __ ] i could i handled it for
about a month and a half and i just said
[ __ ] it i can't take it and i walked out
in some ways i can see how you could
like because you'd be like well it
becomes second nature so you can just
like think about something else yeah you
get up
yeah see i don't know if i could do that
though i kind of feel like i don't i
really don't like
doing repetitive tasks
um you know even if it's something you
don't have to think about all that much
it's still
i don't know i i can't really like let
myself lose
you know go off into my own fantasy land
or whatever
yeah so i don't think i'd be able to
stand that i probably i'd go insane like
easily
best job you ever had
uh what
best one
man i'd have to be [ __ ] in the army
of course but [ __ ]
up on the dmz there's the best and the
worst it has to be something that's real
[ __ ] impressive something that just
kind of like it was just trauma-based
[ __ ] job that was like man and being
being young helped
um
[ __ ] i love being loved working on
the dmz in [ __ ] korea
um
i loved going to egypt with the [ __ ]
101st airborne division the mfo mission
that was fun
um
worked for something called atap as it
was a terrorist unit it was [ __ ] the
trip um
that's all that's all i'm gonna talk
about
worst job i had
was at a mall record store
um
i hate
people
i hate customer service
i hate having to be your job is customer
service no i'm saying
dealing with dumb ass people like every
day
yeah at this store like these are mall
people yeah
in 1993.
man what the hell happened to this yeah
and
i think i only worked there for maybe
like three months and then i got fired
because i just couldn't like deal with
it people were like stupid and
they just want you to be like fake
friendly to everybody they want you to
like call out people that you thought
were stealing stuff i'm just kind of
like yeah you guys are not paid that was
that was minimum wage i was like [ __ ]
that noise i'm not [ __ ] doing that
i don't want to get punched in my face
for 4 35 an hour
which is what it was in 1993 so that was
the worst job that sucked a lot um
[Music]
best job probably well this one
if this could be considered a job i
don't know if it's a i guess it's a job
i make money at it but
i don't really consider it a job because
it's just most the time it's just fun
it's stressful but it's fun too
probably the best kind of traditional
job i had was at
uh van gogh
vodka
which um
we used to i used to work at a liquor
distribution company
they made
it well they didn't make it but they
imported van gogh vodka into the united
states
from holland
and they also had some other liquor
brands like tap 357 whiskey from canada
and uh lucid absinthe i can't remember
where they make that and uh so they had
all these brands
and it was just this really nice little
office it was in orlando
and
very small all the people really nice
and we had a really nice big fancy bar
in the [ __ ] office
and on fridays
especially if we had like a new flavor
of liquor come out they'd have all the
employees and they would give everybody
a drink so you could try out you know
they try out new cocktails and stuff
like that so if they were going to try
it a new flavor or try a new cocktail
like everybody got to taste them on
friday afternoons
and i was like man this is the only this
is amazing i get to [ __ ] drink on the
job
it was excellent and i had my own little
i didn't have my own office but i had my
own really nice little cubicle it was
kind of like back
you know in the back like behind the
wall nobody bothered me
um you know everybody just i was pretty
much the only graphic designer
so
you know they would just come over like
i said everybody's really nice and
they're just kind of like oh we're doing
this promo with this new
espresso vodka it's this new cocktail
they're introducing so i had to make
like little bar menus and all this other
kind of stuff that you know to
distribute all over the country and it
was like it was super fun i mean that
was a sweet [ __ ] job
unfortunately the place
uh
closed captioning not
it available i'm not either
um and that's why
i mean when i find a job that i can live
with i mean i worked for
a weekly newspaper i worked with a
daytona penny saver for years and then i
worked for the news journal the paper in
uh you know in daytona beach for years
just because i think i liked that job
because it was night shift
um the less people generally the less
people that i have to deal with in
person the better the happier i'm gonna
be um so the fact that i worked on night
shift
uh everybody that worked with me there
was only four of us
um you know that worked at the graphic
designers that worked on the night shift
everybody was cool
no there were no managers there nobody
was breathing down our necks they said
as long as you get the work done we
don't really give a [ __ ] what you do
so we would just get the work done and
then we just like
sit around shooting the [ __ ] you know
listening to music
reading audiobooks like listen to
audiobooks or whatever it was like super
fun so i liked that too
and i worked there a long time a long
time
but
i don't know i'm gonna give van gogh the
edge just because
that's the only place i ever worked
where they had booze in the office
you couldn't just like wander in there
any time of day
and drink the booze
but at least once a week they did have a
little kind of get-together where they
were like hey here's a new cocktail we
thought of because they had somebody
employed there that was their job
to come up with new
iterations of like all the drinks that
they had so they would try out new stuff
on the employees to see what's like do
you like this more of this more that you
know so we would try that stuff out
but yeah that was super fun
i had this one job too this is
this is a really weird job this is just
this just goes to show that
there's all kind of like these just
strange little jobs that nobody ever
thinks about
i had a job
back in
the mid 90s the early to mid 90s
and it was at
a little company in daytona beach
and their whole
product the whole thing that they did
was that they produced
these massive
hand-drawn
um
kind of like stylized
maps
of cities in florida they would like to
sell them to tourists
what they would do
is that if you wanted your business
drawn on this map
you had to pay a fee
so they could put your you put your logo
on there
and they had them like i said they were
super cute they had like little
caricatures of people on them and stuff
it was actually kind of accurate to what
the city actually looked like
but
you know they only the businesses that
paid
they would put their business on there
and they'd you know if you paid more
they'd make your sign a little bit
bigger and [ __ ] like that
so i worked at a business that produced
those
so my whole job and that was also night
shift
my whole job was to go in in the
afternoon and i had this big i had a
little desk there was me and one other
guy that worked there i think his name
was jay something
and um we would go in and like we had
all these pens and markers and all this
other kind of stuff and we would just
draw so we drew it by hand now that now
they would do it
digitally
but
drawing maps by hand
you'd have like all these they'd send
you all these pictures like the
businesses would send you all these
pictures this is my restaurant this is
what the sign looks like so you'd have
to like draw it
in the space kind of
similar to where it was
you know and you had to like is you know
it had to be this much percent
percentage bigger than this other
business because they paid more and all
this other kind of stuff says our
connection's good yeah every time i look
here my shit's [ __ ] hung up
are you guys in the live chat are we are
we breaking up a lot nobody's saying
anything okay it must just be me
yeah it's just you i'm good
every time i look down there damn thing
spin it
oh yeah
i don't think it's me
but it still says green yeah
i mean you know
so i don't know every time i look down
it's just [ __ ] spinning loading
loading loading so i don't know nobody's
complaining so i guess yeah grampa's
hammer said you're good okay okay so
it's just you yeah
but yeah so when i think back on it i'm
like wow what a weird [ __ ] job that
was yeah i never had any um
ambitions
for any kind of normal [ __ ] job they
just all look like now and do that they
all look [ __ ] boring
i like [ __ ] military paramilitary
like law enforcement [ __ ] i would
even [ __ ] go you know
i would do some crazy [ __ ] my friend
[ __ ] there's gonna they're gonna make
a movie about my friend [ __ ]
vamvaccus he [ __ ] started doing work
contracting
for central american intelligence
agencies and put politicians there and
eventually gravitated towards [ __ ] um
training and running the [ __ ]
international band of mercenaries
and
tr those that band of mercenaries
trained the mexican drug cartels
his name is [ __ ] timothy vanvaccius
you just googled that [ __ ] name
there's i got pictures of me and vam
together we're in the same yearbooks
together [ __ ] up in korea
he's a james bond
all right he's doing time he's he's in
he's in captivity right now they got him
for uh
killing the dea agent
down in central america
but they don't tell the details
we don't know why i don't they don't
i don't know if he knew it was a dea
agent or maybe the de agent was corrupt
because just because the guy's d8 is me
good
you know uh but some client ordered him
to kill that guy
but they were running a central american
hit squad death squad
i would love to have done some [ __ ] like
that if the money was good
and here's the thing
sounds criminal all special operations
are criminal he was working for
governments
central american governments
doing that
um
the contracting world can get into some
[ __ ] very gray areas but we were
watching [ __ ]
we were
watching
watching die hard last night all this
[ __ ] european [ __ ] mercenaries
doing that damn bank that heist in that
[ __ ]
building
and i was like man vampacus was doing
[ __ ] like that
just crazy [ __ ] man
but uh look look up they got his whole
rap sheet on there the feds [ __ ]
uh but anyway uh
so i never really liked anything that
was normal
we were at the club one time
and had this young kid and he's with
this girl named bree that we knew she
was this goth girl she's all cute
[ __ ] stripper
and he's dating her he's probably two
years younger than her
he's happy like a pig and [ __ ] with this
girl
he's probably about just turning 21
maybe
she dumped him
he shows up to the club he's looking all
[ __ ] sad and [ __ ]
so
it's funny these guys don't have any
father figures or anything you know
[ __ ] nobody tells him what to do and
he's just like i don't know what i'm
gonna do now this is what did you think
you were gonna do you thought at your
age you were just gonna stay up in this
bar
and uh drink and live with these girls
and live off of strippers just by for
being cute and [ __ ] you're not bringing
anything to the table
yeah i got to do something you know
yeah i did think that that was yeah
[Laughter]
that's what you think you know so i kind
of told him what my background was oh
you haven't been here the whole time
says no dude i have not been in this bar
the whole time
yeah we've just been in the bar since
1982. yeah nobody teaches these kids
anything you know
well when they're young they don't know
yeah they just see us older as people in
there and think oh they must have just
been here the whole time like they're
just a bunch of drunks so i told him
about my military but you know my
military adventures and he's like i
don't know if i want to go in the
military though
and i said this is what you need to do
you need to find a gig that's hard that
nobody wants to do it and they make a
lot of money
he goes i'm going to do that i'm going
to do that and that [ __ ]
vanished a year later this big
[ __ ] [ __ ] hits me on the
[ __ ] shoulder how you doing i didn't
recognize him cuz you remember me
and once i realized it wasn't like yeah
yeah where the what the [ __ ] man he's
[ __ ] big and [ __ ] and he goes right
after we got done done talking i hit the
[ __ ] newspapers and looked around and
took your advice and i says i got me a
real job [ __ ] just like what you said
and this is what is he because i work on
an oil rig that says no [ __ ] he goes
yeah i just [ __ ] carry a lot of money
in that yeah [ __ ] i just carry around
these big sacks of [ __ ] sand and i'm
a crewman on the oil rig and i'm getting
my [ __ ] divers license i'm going to
go down in there and [ __ ] weld on
that [ __ ] weld on it on the rig yeah
they pay a lot of money for that because
a lot of people don't want to do it i
mean well it's really dangerous yeah and
he was like he was like and he says dude
that was the best advice you could ever
give us exactly what i was looking for
and he's [ __ ] it just dude just
loaded bristling with [ __ ] muscles
he's gone most of the time and he goes i
didn't have women problems anymore man
i'm gonna i do whatever i want he says
you know look at i got so much money do
whatever i want he became a james bond
of the oil rig world and look you are my
son now yeah i never saw the [ __ ]
after that he went back off to the sea
you know and in the ocean in the sea
that's a that's
that's some bad ass [ __ ] you i respect
that because i couldn't live out there
i've done it i know it's out there right
right now i'm going to tell you sick
[ __ ] the ocean [ __ ] that ocean i grew up
right like right next to the ocean [ __ ]
the ocean lots of danger but that is
exactly what he was looking for young
man got to put his [ __ ] in danger or
he's just not gonna feel good about
himself it's a testosterone level
not all of them but there's just a
certain kind of guy that is like that
you bring it out of them
well like i said everybody has different
things that they like and different
things they're good at yeah you just got
to find something that aligns with that
that'll give you enough money to feed
yourself the only thing that's close to
that outside in the civilian world
if it's not the ocean then right at
right after that closest thing would be
trucking
guys in trucker trucking and railroad
um
[ __ ] truckers are [ __ ] that's a
that's a hard life
you know
i respect that too but you know honestly
i think
my personality i think is well suited to
being a trucker oh yeah you probably
would because you just [ __ ] sit there
and drive and [ __ ] manage your
business and you get to certain places
that's what i mean i've thought about
that a few times there wasn't so many
like [ __ ] serial killers on the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
i've kind of thought of that sometimes
i'm like you know what maybe maybe
someday be a long haul trucker i'd be a
yeah well it appeals to me because i i
kind of like just being by myself for a
long time i kind of like
not having anybody around telling you
what to do like you just kind of have a
goal you have to be at this location at
this time
and you don't really have anybody
telling you
like micromanaging you all the time like
it's like well i'll get there by that
time i'll just like manage my own [ __ ]
i like managing my own [ __ ] another real
rough one that you can make a lot of
money at is them damn fishermen way up
north in that cold water up there yeah
they make a lot of money dude well i
think it depends on the boat but yeah
that's a hard life
yeah
honestly those dudes made a lot of money
yeah i don't know about it i think it
depends on what you're fishing for yeah
but um
yeah i wouldn't want to do anything on
the ocean because i'm yeah [ __ ] the
ocean like i said i grew up and i grew
up on the coast
right by the ocean and the ocean is full
of sharks in case you guys didn't know
and um also i've seen too many episodes
of i shouldn't be alive with shipwrecks
and stuff no thanks no thanks a lot of
danger
um yeah well
i'll stand the land certain kind of
people just thrive on that that they
can't live without it
yeah i understand it totally
it's just not my style i like to be on
the ground or in the air
i wouldn't have any problem flying i
love flying see i don't like flying i
love it
i love it i'm a ground-based organism
i have to hang out the side of the
[ __ ] chopper with the [ __ ] doors
open and [ __ ] looking around [ __ ]
throw a cigarette out sneaking
cigarettes in the [ __ ] chopper yeah
but you don't sleep smoking in there but
leave it anyway
yeah elsa said i can't stand being
micromanaged i can't either i mean
honestly that's why all of the best jobs
that i had were jobs where people just
said we need you to do this and left me
alone to do it at my own pace and time i
do not like that's why i didn't like
working in retail i don't like being
constantly
monitored
um i just don't like it i like being
given a goal and then be like okay just
do it and i'm gonna leave you alone
while you do it i don't like people that
are all up in your grill all the time
like you know
uh mike bird says jenny you are an
artist well thank you honestly mostly
all i've ever wanted to do is just like
write books
write books
design games
do [ __ ] like that
fun [ __ ]
honestly i've been uh
maybe i don't i don't know if it's ever
gonna come out
but
the last couple of weeks
after i get my [ __ ] done like for the
show and any graphic design jobs i have
i've started working on another book
although
it's fiction kind of but it's based on a
non-fic it's based on something that
really happened but it's like a
fictional fictionalized version of it i
don't know if i'll finish or not but i
don't know but i but interestingly
that's what i work on when i want to
like relax and have a good time
so that's how you know that that's
really what you want to do because you
look forward to oh let me get this other
[ __ ] done so i can work on this because
that's
that's the fun thing that's what i want
to do
but you know well i don't know we'll see
how it goes i'll see if i finish it or
not i kind of like how it's going so far
yeah that drafters asked me to [ __ ]
fly for lake county sheriff too old bro
too the only thing that i've been
looking at what could be happening is um
well i ain't gonna talk about it yet
some other [ __ ] happening here in
florida
something a little bit more military
mary connolly fsg if you know what i'm
talking about
they're reviving a unit called the fsg
which was
the florida state guard which that's
world war ii era
one time during world war ii they sent
all the national guard guys to uh to uh
uh
germany they're you know the uh
germany but if i can
hunt to europe
so florida rose its own
national guard called the fsg and they
were veterans and cops you could
join that
so
that got approved
they have the training cash right
together
uh but the budget isn't it's they have
to the staff is 200 and they have a
budget for it
and they would accept um a veteran of my
profile from um uh [ __ ] uh because of
my because my background they'd take me
but they're not hiring yet because
they're they're establishing a training
cataract
so we'll see and it will probably be
volunteer at first
so we'll see if it's volunteer
it'd probably be once a month like the
national guard but we'd see we'll see
we'll see what they do
once it
usually what happens if you have
something like the fsg
it's volunteer for a while and then it
becomes paid
as things develop
but politics are involved
but
mark says i got swole
oscar says tom not wanting to be
underwater is a form of claustrophobia
yeah i'm claustrophobic i don't like um
i'm not claustrophobic i don't like the
ocean because of sharks most i don't
want to be eaten by an animal larger
than myself
especially in the water
um
it's not so much being under water that
bothers me it's
being in the water and one there being
nothing around and you you know you
there's no food there's no you know you
can't drink any water even though
there's a whole thing and also i don't
like
there's this whole like
[ __ ] that's going on underneath you and
you can't see anything yeah so i don't
know if it's so much claustrophobia it's
just i don't like
i don't like floating out somewhere and
i'm not i don't know what's going on
under there and there might be like big
huge sea monsters yeah i don't like that
um sergeant deadhead who's born and
raised in useless florida which but
that's where that's where we are right
now he said his floor you got to be
careful because his florida guard unit
is in africa right now see that was the
reason why they're talking about the fsg
the fsg would be under the direct
command of the governor and the the
federal authorities could not order it
to be deployed overseas you see
which is that's a good thing because
the federal government is kind of
abusing the states at a certain level by
using their national guard units as
troops which that's not what the the
guard was supposed to be
if the feds want to deploy troops they
have to raise their own armies they have
to stop stealing from the from the
states their their their little army
groups
so uh no those are home guard units
you're not supposed to be deploying them
overseas it's because they're cheap and
it's a dying empire if you ask me
so what you do is is the fsg would be
not be under federal command it would be
governor only
which that's what the national guard was
supposed to be
but the feds have usurped that [ __ ]
power
um but this state had a florida state
guard which was
a true state army and they've just
revived it they're going into training
now the training cat should cad race
together
the dicta was that it was [ __ ]
volunteer
so it wouldn't involve a paycheck but
usually how things evolve
in order to keep the group together they
have to start paying them
or they pay select people like i would
apply for a commission to become a
commissioned officer i wouldn't enlist
let's see we'll see how it goes
mary says pole dancers pays a lot yes uh
depends where you are
um
and honestly
man even if i was young and had the body
for that i don't think i'd want to do
that
it's just
you'd be dealing with too many creeps
not enough money
i don't know anymore i don't know if
they could like pay me enough yeah i
think they made more money back in the
old days before internet before internet
right
you know what i mean because back then
like every so now you're getting like
the lowest common denominator yep
you're now sketching around now they're
dudes that are trying to actually pay
for sex is what's true that's what
they're trying that's what i'm saying
it's just kind of like so i i really
don't and honestly like wearing those
big [ __ ] teetering ass shoes and like
[ __ ]
dancing around pretending to like grubby
ass
looking [ __ ] no thanks that
doesn't sound like a lot of fun
i don't think he could pay me enough to
do that [ __ ]
even even if i looked good enough to do
it the money's online
yeah
uh tammy said ever see those pics of a
paddleboarder from above and under him
as a whale or a shark oh yeah yeah um i
remember when i took marine biology in
high school
and
our teacher
i can't remember what her name was
she showed us a photo that had been
taken of daytona beach
and there was like all these little
happy swimmers right here and then like
30 yards out
sharks
after that i lost my enthusiasm about
and i wasn't all that enthusiastic about
going to the ocean anyway like even
before i was a kid because even when i
was a kid i didn't go out super super
deep but
you know i i went out deep enough where
i was just you know knee-high thigh deep
something like that where you had the
occasional small shark kind of be like
bump against your leg you know what i
mean
and uh that would kind of like be well
oop end of my beach day bye going back
to sit on the sand
but um
i was at the beach a lot as a kid
because my mom loved it so she used to
like take us there all the time like
every weekend
but when i got older and especially
after i saw that picture in high school
i'm like yep i'm not going in the
[ __ ] i'm not going to the [ __ ]
ocean and every time i've been
re-watching
i shouldn't be alive because they have a
bunch of them on uh amazon prime
so i've been re-watching those
and yeah that's just reminding me yeah
let's let's not go out in the middle of
the ocean on a boat for any reason
whatsoever
i kind of feel like most of the people
that are on that show
um
[Music]
most of them if they weren't out there
doing some crazy like extreme sports
kind of [ __ ] they wouldn't have gotten
into that predicament not blaming the
victim
that's it's shitty what happened to them
but
some of the stuff was avoidable was not
avoidable like it was their job or
something like that but
most of the time like there's this one i
saw like these two guys and they were
trying to oh let's
let's ride a cat a catamaran
out to this deserted island or something
like that i can't remember where it was
in the gulf of mexico or some [ __ ] like
that somewhere i don't remember where it
was no it was baja
peninsula i don't remember
and it was known for having like really
really bad weather
and the two of them thought they were
[ __ ] even though they were just like
schlubby like midwestern dudes or
whatever they're just kind of like they
just thought they were [ __ ] superman
and nothing bad was gonna happen
so they decide they're gonna cross this
straight like in shitty weather at night
even though they didn't really know what
they were doing and you know immediately
this [ __ ] storm comes up their
catamarans all [ __ ] up and they're
trapped on this [ __ ] deserted island
12 miles from the shore
no food no nothing
and i was just kind of like well that's
what you get
they got saved though spoiler alert
that's why i shouldn't be alive they
they did live
not all not always though because i did
see one the other day where
they were it was actually a bunch of
people on a boat i can't remember what
they were doing but they were like out
in a boat
and the boat capsized in a real bad
storm that came up out of nowhere
and they were all experienced sailors
and [ __ ] so they knew
they knew their [ __ ] but this storm just
was like real sudden
and
i think only two of them ended up living
most of them
after the boat capsized got eaten by
sharks but two of them still ended up
living the grossest thing about that was
they were in that [ __ ]
lifeboat
and then one of the one of the people
died in the lifeboat
and then like all her corpse juices
were like in the water in the bottom and
everybody's like pee and poop was in
there ugh they were all starting to get
sick from that it was super gross
man that was that was they didn't know
how to take care of themselves that was
a bad that was a bad episode i was just
like you know that one and there's
there's a bunch of like people that were
like out hiking in the snow and [ __ ]
like that those ones but
[ __ ] man
jenny i'm getting uh worn out i have to
go i'm gonna have to clean up downstairs
elsa said oh my god i took a pole
dancing class a few years ago and i
don't know how much
i don't have much upper body strength
it's [ __ ] hard yeah that's what i'm
saying i kind of feel like people just
be like oh pole dancing blah blah blah
but yeah that's it's a skill just like
anything else yeah
it's funny though you girls [ __ ] say
oh it's hard this and that work out
working out is hard but you get stronger
it the response is pretty quick
it's easy you get strong faster why
don't you go pull dance and time i can
oh i'm putting stronger pull dance let's
put some big high heels on we'll put you
some pasties on you're trying to give me
a [ __ ] put some of course that puts
the corset on put that [ __ ] up on the
only fans yeah right he's trying to play
[ __ ] chicken but he's he's never
going to do it
well you're safe because you're never
going to do it
you can talk [ __ ] whatever you want
saying that you're not going to do it
though
just saying
[ __ ] pole dance i don't give a [ __ ]
mark says pookie where are you
she was in here earlier she got bored of
us talking i guess and she wanted like
she was like why are you guys talking to
lights she's like why are you not
talking to me
i'm just i'm now i'm kind of curious i
almost want to put
uh eminoter's jug band christmas on
again to see if she stares at it yeah to
see if she stares at those little otter
he's asking about um
has anybody seen tom hardy's uh
capone capone is it any good
that's where that dude did that i like
everything he's in i heard about that
and then i kind of i wanted to see it
and then i heard like mixed reviews
like some people said it was like
[ __ ] brilliant and some people said
it was terrible
so i wasn't really sure
i've liked every movie that dude was in
i have as well so i'm sure it's probably
like worth watching
yeah i know i feel bad that pookie
didn't she was in here when we first
started the stream but then she like
wandered off she probably wandered off
and fell asleep somewhere she's not in
that sync is she sometimes she falls
asleep in that sink over there
she must have like gone into herself
where'd he go
yeah kick me off my own show
yeah get the [ __ ] off yeah
well no we still got you left all that
food out downtown i know i got a lot of
work i got to do and i can't get too
blasted or i'll [ __ ] fall down with a
turkey in my hand
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be funny [ __ ] funny
take a picture that mean laying on the
[ __ ]
with a turkey leg on your face
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't even have any m m's i'm just
thinking you throwing something on me
okay
don't question the poultry guys
it says what it says
[ __ ]
yeah i mean
i might get a piece of apple pie i
really want some apple pie but i don't i
just don't know if i'm hungry enough to
enjoy it i gotta put that turkey wedge
in
okay
all right so
anyway
you guys have a very very happy
christmas eve if you're celebrating and
you know tomorrow is obviously christmas
day we haven't opened a presents yet
we're gonna open the presents tomorrow
morning
little pooky's gonna open a presents
beijing i got them like a couple
presents for for them okay
so everybody have a really good
christmas
be safe if you're out and about and we
will talk to you guys again on sunday
we'll probably do a movie review
so everybody have happy holidays out
there
merry christmas and we will see you guys
on sunday
bye